Hau, mein Mikrofon funktioniert!
Der Wackelkontakt in meinem Verlängerungskabel ist nämlich schlechter geworden und jetzt
hat es zwischenzeitlich schon Aussetzer, wenn ich einfach nur ein bisschen was oben
auf dem Schreibtisch rumrücke, deswegen wundern sie mich, dass es jetzt funkt, ich muss das
Kabel unbedingt mal austauschen, aber das ist nicht einfach nur ein Kabel, das ist halt
Mute-Button und Kabel in einem, es ist sehr praktisch einen extra Mute-Button zu haben.
Das ist uralt, das ist richtig, richtig alt, was ich da hab zum verlängern, wartet mal,
ich zeige euch mal kurz, das war, das ist noch von dem allerersten Headset, was ich jemals
hatte, also das ist bestimmt 20 Jahre alt, aber das war ein Microsoft Sidewinder Headset,
war ich damals, genau dieses Billigding, Alter, hatte ich damals, hatte ich damals, ich glaube,
das hab ich geschenkt bekommen, ja, das war das erste, genau das Ding, Alter, das war
das erste Headset, was ich je hatte, übelster Crap, Leute, richtig Massive Crap, guckt euch
das mal an, Alter, das war auf Ear, wie nennt man das, On Ear, also das hat auf dem Ohr
drauf gesessen, das Mikrofon war absoluter Müll, aber was ich bis heute verwende, ist
dieses Verlängerungsding hier, dieses Verlängerungskabel verwende ich bis heute noch, es hat einen
Mute-Button und du kannst mit den Knöpfen theoretisch noch verschiedene Audio-Channels
und sowas durchschalten, wobei, das verwende ich nicht, ich benutze es eigentlich nur als
Verlängerung und Mute-Button, man hat einen Mute-Button für Sound und einen Mute-Button
für Mikrofon, beziehungsweise, nee, man hat einen Mute-Button für Sound und für Mikrofon,
und das ist halt so kaputt schon, das ist erschienen 2003 oder so, 2005, ok, sprich,
es ist 18 Jahre alt jetzt, also 18 Jahre alt ist das Verlängerungskabel, was ich verwende
für mein Bio-Dynamics gerade, halt wegen dem Mute-Button, das ist so kaputt mittlerweile,
das ist so wackelkontaktig alles, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, ob das gescheit funktioniert
im Stream, Battlefield 2042 macht ja immer mal Probleme, ich muss auf jeden Fall umschalten,
von Display-Capture auf Game-Capture gleich, sonst klappt das Ganze nicht, hab ich überhaupt
noch Platz auf der Platte hier, ich hoffe, ich hab's noch installiert, hab ich's noch
installiert, ja ok, noch mal Glück gehabt, noch mal Glück gehabt, wo ist der Ton, ist
da, geht alles, aber mein Mikrofon ist falsch eingestellt, laut, Moin Patrick, Dankeschön
für den Sub, Twitch Mason, Dankeschön für den Massive Sub, Maus-Input sollte besser
sein, egal, Pepega Aim ist wieder am Start, Leute, ich bin mittlerweile 38 und übe Null,
was Shooter angeht, schon seit einer Weile, weil es nichts gibt, was ich gerne spiele,
also Pepega Aim ist hier am Start, wobei es tatsächlich ganz gut läuft, also ist es nicht,
aber in Battlefield verliert man nicht, was, schließe jede Stufe ab, was zum, das sieht
jetzt anders aus, ach guck mal, das ist jetzt der Boost Train, das ist jetzt nicht der Sub,
das ist der Boost Train, TS Fuchs, Dankeschön für den Sub, so, ok, das muss jetzt erstmal
Shader kompilieren und drei Stunden irgendwelche Dinger machen, Postchamp, Postchamp, Postchamp,
Postchamp, Tatsächlich, funktioniert einfach, nice, ich meine, die Musik mag vielleicht
ganz gut dazu passen, aber die machen wir gleich aus, so, erst mal umschalten, Game Capture
auf Battlefield, weil ansonsten bug das nämlich rum, kann ich gleich umschalten, Job, Dankeschön
für den Sub, guck mal, sogar die Animation ruckelt schon, das Game macht im Hauptmenü
ultra viel CPU-Last, ich weiß nicht warum, guckt euch das mal an, Keckl, fuck, das ist
das Hauptmenü, wollen die New World Konkurrenz machen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, mit
Grafikkarten, die verrecken, ja guck hier, Skip Frames, Encoding Lag, aber das ist nicht
schlimm, wenn ich hier umschalte auf in Game Capture ist alles gut, also den Sinn habe
ich noch nicht so genau verstanden, ehrlich gesagt, warum das eine besser ist als das,
aber ok, ok, man will es ja, Shitcoin, man, ja wirkt echt so, ich, wisst ihr was wir mal
schnell gucken mussten, gibt es vielleicht eine Option, gibt es eine Option um im Hauptmenü,
ich meine, ok, ist jetzt rhetorische Frage, ja, gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht, aber gibt
es eine Option um im Hauptmenü die FPS zu limitieren, mein FOV scheint mir hier ein
bisschen niedrig, muss ich gleich mal gucken ob das stimmt, kann man FPS limitieren, Vertical
Sync, naja ne, das wollen wir ja nicht, ne ich glaube das geht nicht, also sprich, wenn
man heizen will, einfach mal Battlefield anschmeißen, vielleicht, wir fragen mal Reddit dazu, Reddit
weiß doch bei sowas immer Bescheid, ja es ist ja eigentlich Strom statt Erdgas, aber
man könnte es auch, Battlefield, das wäre dann quasi, Battlefield anstatt Erdgas, es
braucht alles Abkürzungen, Fix Low High CPU Usage, naja, mir geht es nur im Hauptmenü,
als Hauptmenü über Main, 100% CPU Usage, da kann man nichts dran ändern wahrscheinlich,
you can't fix it, DICE is aware of it, ach ja, ich würde sagen DICE lack critical information,
weil bis jetzt hat DICE das ganze noch nicht gefixt, wie vieles andere in dem Spiel auch,
aber sie scheinen critical information nicht wirklich zu lacken bei DICE, sondern sie haben
keinen Bock die critical information zu verarbeiten, yeah, brutal expectations so siehts aus, ja
also hier einen Sleep einzubauen im Hauptmenü, das stelle ich mir auch schon extrem krass
vor das zu fixen, ist bestimmt komplett, die Technik ist einfach, die Technologie ist
einfach noch nicht da Leute, und jetzt seht ihr warum ich 32 GB RAM habe, also ich Battlefield
starten kann, VMs offen haben kann, 120 Browser Tabs offen haben kann, alles kein Problem,
ja ja.
Habt ihr übrigens mitbekommen, dass der Typ mit dem russischen Gas gebannt wurde auf Twitch,
es gab nen Streamer, der hat den ganzen Tag seinen Gasherd angehabt und hat halt durch
gefeuert und es wurde gebannt, ich weiß ob er einen neuen Account hat, tja, ach ja übrigens,
wo wir gerade dabei sind, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen
hat, also das habe ich mir genauso gedacht als ich das gelesen habe, ich hab von Anfang
an nie diese Faszination, die da manche aufbringen konnten, für Game Streaming verstanden, ok,
aber ich dachte mir so, ja in gewisser Weise theoretisch hat das Potential, praktisch wird
das nichts und man sieht mal wieder, es wurde nichts, deswegen kann ich auch nicht verstehen,
was die Logitech CEOs und Top-Manager geritten hat, jetzt nen Streaming Handheld rauszubringen.
Streaming daheim auf dem Desktop klappt doch schon nicht, bzw. was heißt klappt nicht,
im Prinzip klappt das schon, will aber keiner haben und dass das Mobile dann über Mobilfunk
noch ordentlich funktionieren soll, ich mein ich hab ja schon Probleme Twitter zu refreshen
wenn ich heimfahre und ich fahre heim von Frankfurt nach Hanau, also muss man sich mal
auf der Zunge zergehen hassen, das dürfte so eines der meistgefahrenen Strecken in Deutschland
sein, also ich fahre hier Frankfurt, ich fahre von Hauptbahnhof, so und ich fahre im Prinzip
hier lang, so, das ist quasi eines der meistgefahrenen, ne nicht die S-Bahn, das dürfte eines der
meistgefahrenen Strecken, warum will der mir die S-Bahn aufladen, eines der meistgefahrenen
Strecken überhaupt sein in Deutschland, Frankfurt-Hanau oder Frankfurt-Köln und selbst da hab ich
Mobile-Aussetzer, wie stellen die sich das überhaupt vor, so jetzt machen wir mal Battlefield
an, weil ich merke schon es leckt wieder as fuck, ich wohne im Ghetto, meinst du das Frankfurter
Ghetto oder das Hanauer Ghetto, also ich wohne nicht in der Nidderstraße in Frankfurt, übrigens
Fun Fact aus Frankfurt, wo wir gerade dabei sind, Fun Fact aus Frankfurt, Nidderstraße
und Münchnerstraße und die Ecke, Kaiserstraße, da wo die ganzen Drogenabhängigen und Kriminellen
rumhängen, da war es jetzt so schlimm, dass sich quasi die Ladenbesitzer dort, haben
sich im Stich gelassen, gefühlt von der Polizei und haben daraufhin einen privaten Sicherheitsdienst
angeheuert, der dort dann quasi die ganzen Drogenabhängigen vertreibt und Kriminellen
vertreibt und als die Polizei das mitbekommen hat, haben sie gesagt, ja das sehen sie aber
nicht gerne, dann haben die Ladenbesitzer gesagt, ja dann kommt doch öfters vorbei
und jetzt kommt die Polizei öfters vorbei und dann scheint alles wieder gut zu sein,
ich frag mich warum es erst wieder so ausarten muss, übrigens eine Story muss ich euch noch
erzählen, wo wir gerade bei Frankfurt sind, wo wir gerade bei Frankfurt sind, bevor wir
in Berlin kommen, wir bauen uns mal nebenbei eine Klasse, by the way das Game hat gerade
wirklich keinen Sound, wir müssen gleich mal checken, ob die Lautstärke passt, so wir
bauen mal ganz kurz was zusammen, was wollte ich euch denn jetzt gerade noch erzählen,
genau also eine witzige Story, eigentlich ist es eher bedenklich in Frankfurt, ich muss
das Ding übrigens mal ordentlich benennen, wie ging umbenennen nochmal, ah obviously
rechts klick, rename links klick, ah fuck, rename, hallo ich möchte es markieren, nicht
erlaubt, nicht im Scope, ah 40 oder wie dieses Ding heißt, ah hab gedacht ich weiß was es
ist, ah m40 heißt das Ding, so also nochmal Funfact aus dem Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel,
ja also als wir da mal Mittagessen gewesen sind, also dass ich euch mal so grob vorstellen
kann, was grob vorstellen könnt, was da so abgeht, also Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel ist
quasi das hier, also wenn du hier aus dem Hauptbahnhof rauskommst, ah, aus dem Hauptbahnhof
rauskommst, hier daneben war Taunusstraße, Nidderstraße, sonst wie das hier ist Bahnhofsviertel,
das ist da wo die ganzen kriminellen drogenabhängigen Assis sind, das geht im Endeffekt dann so
hoch hier bis zum Willy Brandt Platz und dann hier am Main und zurück, also das hier ist
so quasi das Bahnhofsviertel, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es vielleicht sogar bis
zur Zeil noch mit zählt, aber so richtig die Assis die sind eigentlich hier am Hauptbahnhof,
so und wir waren was futtern, das müsste, das müsste hier, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau,
das müsste hier irgendwie so in der Ecke gewesen sein und auf einmal, das hab ich euch
glaube ich schon mal erzählt, Recycle Story, ich weiß, auf einmal gegenüber auf der Straßenseite
siehst du zwei Mädels laufen und auf einmal kommt von hinten so ein Typ angesprintet,
haut der einen auf den Kopf, schnappt sich die Tasche und rennt weg und man denkt sich
so, Frankfurt und naja, kacke das da so an hellichtem Tag auf offener Straße, aber noch
viel besser, noch viel besser, als der losgerannt ist hat sie ihm hinterhergeschrien, Karl,
ich weiß, ich glaub es war Karl, so Karl was machst du, das heißt die kannten sich,
die wussten wer das war, das sind alte Leute, ihr seid so fertig dort, der Wahnsinn, die
muss einfach zur Polizei gehen und sagen, guck mal, der Karl hat mich überfallen, ich
weiß sogar wo er wohnt, die kennen sich, die sind ganz dicke, wahrscheinlich geht die
noch nicht mal zur Polizei, ich glaub ich geh die nachher beim Karl vorbei und sag hier
gib mal die Tasche wieder, die sind so fertig in Frankfurt, das ist unglaublich, das ist
wirklich der Wahnsinn und gerade diese Ecke hier unten, diese hier, Niederstraße, Moselstraße,
Niederstraße und hier vorne Taunerstraße, aber gerade das hier unten, das ist wirklich
absolut der, das ist richtig Frankfurter Ghetto, also wenn es in Frankfurt eins gibt, dann
diese Ecke hier unten, das ist auch das Mosel-Eck, so die ekligste Kneipe von außen, die ich,
ich war noch nie drinne, die sieht von außen schon so eklig aus, dass ich da nie reingehen
würde, naja gut, wie dem auch sei, genug Frankfurt Bahnhof, Bahnhof Vettel Stories, so, übrigens
wisst ihr was mir aufgefallen ist, was auch ein Legacy-Feature ist, oh Moment, ich muss
ja so Game Capture machen, sonst funzt das ganze ja nicht, dort mal Abonnenten treffen,
genau, so, wisst ihr was mir aufgefallen ist, was auch Legacy-Feature ist, wenn ihr hier
drauf geht und wollt die Waffe modifizieren, ja, und ihr sagt jetzt, hm, eigentlich will
ich das Ding hier komplett rauslöschen wieder, dass es gar nicht drin steht, das geht nicht,
es gibt, es gibt keinen Button, es gibt keinen Button, um Attachments wieder zu entfernen,
Legacy-Feature, braucht man nicht, das war ja auch nicht im Scope, komm, ich bin heute
mal, komm, wir spielen heute mal tatsächlich mit, mit irgendeinem, nicht, nicht, ihr wisst,
ich bin großer Ironside-Enjoyer, großer Ironside-Enjoyer, aber, guck mal was besser ist, aber wir machen
heute mal, wir machen heute mal tatsächlich einen, einen Scope drauf, so habe ich irgendwas
ordentliche schon anlockt, übrigens, das ist normal, das hat anscheinend keine Musik
im Menü, weiß auch nicht warum, Trommelmagazin brauchen wir noch, ok, Pogu, ach alles Müll
brauchen wir nicht, gut, so, lassen wir mal so, so, was probieren wir dann sonst noch
aus, also ich habe jetzt für mich, wenn gar nichts läuft, wenn gar nichts läuft, kann
ich die SMGs rausholen, damit geht eigentlich immer was, ansonsten die neue Waffe, die ist
auch relativ nice, was können wir denn machen, komm, wir probieren mal, nee, nee, nee, Schneiber,
VK, Schneiber spielen wir nicht, das sieht eher aus wie eine Submachine Gun, oder, das
ist eine Submachine Gun, Magasin-Size, Mag-Size, 30, Utility, nee, nee, Auto-Shotgun, nee,
nee, sowas, sowas, Leute, übrigens, das ist alles, mehr gibt es nicht, also, muss ich
mal vorstellen, es passt quasi, ohne wirklich zu scrollen, alles an Waffen-Selection, ein
Jahr nach Release, immer noch alles hier unten auf einem Bildschirm, habt ihr mal, nur mal
so, ich weiß, es ist ein ganz ganz dober Vergleich, aber ich muss jetzt einfach mal bringen,
habt ihr mal von Dota 2 die Heldenauswahl gesehen, das erschlägt dich förmlich, das sind mittlerweile
irgendwie 125, okay, das gibt es auch 10 Jahre oder so schon, aber, es ist halt auch was,
wo du Zeug auswählen kannst, und dazu gibt es auch viel viel mehr, und hier passt halt
alles, was da unten ist, was ich unlockt habe, EP29, Jack, was muss man machen, um die M16
zu unlocken, hm, ach hier, da oben, was muss man machen, Kill and Assists with Underbarrelk,
ich muss noobtuben, um die M16 freizuschalten, ernsthaft, und Kills und Assists mit das Svarmlgl,
also mit der SVM Grenade Launcher, oh, fuck, Alter, muss das wirklich sein, ja, ich muss
noobtube Kills machen, na gut, komm her, wo ist denn das Ding überhaupt, Svarmgl, alles
klar, auf geht's, das ist auch noch so eine Low Rate of Fire Crap Weapon, was sind das
hier, ist der noobtube da schon standardmäßig, eh, immerhin, immerhin ist der noobtube standardmäßig
dabei, Mag Size 20 ist komplett für'n Bobbes, ich hab das Ding noch nie gespielt, Underbarrelk
Shotgun, oh ja, das wär nice, zählt das auch, äh, Zack, ich will das customisen, Visier,
Visier hab ich noch nie gespielt, ok, komm, wir noobtube unlock, komm on, auf geht's,
komm, warte, wie war das, Rechtsklick, Rename, übrigens Hauptmenü hat kein Sound, das ist
nicht so, dass der fehlen würde, noobtube, confirm, so, was machen wir dann sonst noch,
secondary, ne, zu viel PP, die ist Single Fire, die sieht überhaupt nicht so aus, seriously,
es gibt ganze 5 Pistolen, ernsthaft, dachte eigentlich mittlerweile ist mehr, aber ok,
anscheinend nicht, so, Med Pack, Meddings, Proxy Sensor, dann haben wir wieder Frag mit,
so, auf geht's, zack, Rush, Bam, so, wir müssen gleich mal kurz gucken, wie das Sound ist,
ich baller mal kurz ein bisschen in der Gegend rum und ihr müsst mir sagen, ob das so passt,
weil Windows und Sound Settings, ich hab das zwar eingestellt, ey, der Sound kommt schon
noch, wartet mal ab, ich mein, ok, ein bisschen lauter kann ich glaube ich jetzt schon machen,
ja ja doch, das Sound ist doch alles da, achja, vielleicht sollte ich VoIP ausschalten, wenn
ich nämlich VoIP anhabe, laber ich, our class Rush, MonkaS, ok, das ist gut zum testen,
das ist gut zum testen, baller ich ein bisschen in der Gegend rum, ich muss VoIP ausschalten,
sonst schwätze ich die Leute in Game zu, falls es standardmäßig keinen Push to Talk hat,
ich trau denen ja alles zu, Spiel hängt, hallo, übrigens wisst ihr was, in MW2 2022 kann man
sogar die Loadouts und sowas angucken, sowas im Respawn Bildschirm und sowas, stellt euch
mal vor, achso, kann man hier auch, ich hab nix gesagt, wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz
schauen, wie mach ich denn hier, Settings, Settings, wo sind denn die Settings, Options,
Sound, VoIP, wo macht man VoIP aus, ach, deswegen hab ich keine Musik, lull, die ich ausgeschaltet
hab, wo könnte VoIP sein, bei Voice Chat, wo ist denn Voice Chat, wo, ach da, Alter,
ich hab keine Güte, Voice Chat aus, das ist aber auch wirklich kacke zu sehen, ich komm,
ne, ich noobtube nicht, lass mal hier, irgendwie was halbwegs sinnvolles machen, aber Hour
Class, ich glaub Hour Class geh ich wirklich gleich wieder, so, den da, Hour Class geh
ich gleich wieder raus, so, Lautstärkentest, scheint okay zu sein, oder, müsste eigentlich
ganz gut passen, es dürfte auch nicht ruckeln und so, müsste eigentlich alles passen, wobei
man bei dem Game nie weiß, also bei dem Game kann es auch durchaus sein, sag mal Spawn,
raipen wir die gerade, sag mal, wer die gerade gesp-, ah die Runde hat erst angefangen,
okay, oh, lag, ruckel, stellts, was ist hier los, oh da unten läuft was, ne, ne, ne, oh
da ist ein Tank, ach ich vergaß, man kann ja gar nicht spotten, spotten von, funzt ja
gar nicht richtig, kann man, kann man an den Baum crappeln, oh das ist ne schlechte Idee,
da bin ich total exposed, sieht das Game immer so matschig aus, ich seh mir grad die Vorschau
an, ja, ja, sieht es, die Vorschau ist in Ordnung, die Container, ja die Map wurde noch nicht
überarbeitet, die ist noch im Ursprungszustand und ist dementsprechend relativ containerfrei
aber halt schlecht, ich mein die haben es geschafft innerhalb von einem Jahr zwei Maps zu überarbeiten,
es ist halt so das Game hatte eh schon kaum Maps zu Release und die Überarbeitung dauert
halt auch drei Stunden, äh drei Stunden, drei Jahre, also ungefähr drei Stunden hätte
ein fähiger Map Designer für gebraucht das ganze zu, sehr faire Map, ja ich kann nicht
weiter Leute, guck mal wenn ich hier weiter laufe dann ist es out, es gibt nichts was ich
machen kann gerade, die stehen im Spawn und kommen nicht raus, außer dass sie mich gleich
snipen wahrscheinlich, random bin genau, chat wusste dir das ich noch nie in einer Wüste
war, ok, ppega aim ausrufezeichen, wir bräuchten ein ppega aim Counter was haltet ihr davon,
dass man ausrufezeichen ppega aim machen kann, im Chat und dann kann ich am Ende des Streams
gucken wie oft ich ppega aimed habe, oh Chat eine Frage, könntet ihr mal kurz in der
Bitrate gucken vom Stream ob das 7900 MBits sind, müsste 7900 sein, Alter Spawn Rape direkt
in der ersten Rush Runde, das geht ja schon gut los, ist da oben einer drauf, ne der lebt
gar nicht, warte mal was soll ich machen, ich meine, oh ausrufezeichen für ppega aim,
schwankt zwischen 7700 und 8300, ja das ist gut, das ist gut, übrigens wisst ihr was
tatsächlich an der Rush, ich muss die wirklich mal loben, wisst ihr was an der Rush Playlist
wirklich nice ist, die Bad Company 2 Maps sind zum größten Teil drinne, also nein das
stimmt nicht, die Bad Company 2 Maps die drinne sind, die sind zum größten Teil in der Rush
Playlist, das sind ja, oh Alter was lag das so, oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
Gachibas, jawoll, defused easy, ich wäre sogar revived, welche Grafikeinstellung ist
das, zum größten Teil low, ich muss mal meinen Motion Sensor schmeißen, oh oh oh oh, oh,
weggesprengt, vergiss nicht zu NoobTube, ich hab nicht die NoobTube Klasse, Leute wisst
ihr was, die Map ist eh absolute Abfuck, wir switchen auf NoobTube, wie wählt man den
überhaupt aus, x, ok, komm mal da, jetzt wird er genoobtubed, übrigens diese Mikroruckler
sind normal, die hab ich auch, weiß nicht warum, hab ich auf den anderen Maps nicht
gehabt, da kommt was, Achtung, das Auto, Massive NoobTube Massive, nee, war nix, da muss ich
meine MB2 One Man Army, erinnert sich da noch jemand dran, NoobTube One Man Army, meine
MB2 2009 Skills wieder raus rollen, ist das das gleiche Hochhaus mit der gleichen Textur,
das da zumindest, das andere nicht, aber ja, die Map ist nicht sonderlich mit, wie soll
man sagen, mit Hingebungen, mit Liebe zum Detail gemacht, nice, Munition leer, progge,
das ist halt mal richtig räudig jetzt, wenn ich das nur fürs Noobtuben hab, glaub das
mach ich nicht im Stream, das ist richtig blöde, 20 Schuss man, was willst du damit anfangen?
Ach, das ist die Map, wo die ganzen Heli Bros wieder unterwegs sind, das ist bisschen,
die Skyline von Frankfurt in 300 Jahren, wenn das mit globaler Erwärmung so weiter geht,
übrigens die sind blöd, die eigentlich alle zurückfliegen sollen, gut ist, ich renn jetzt
einfach zurück, weil ich geh einfach sterben, easy, Tank, ah, gehst du weg hinter mir man,
ich NoobTube nicht, jetzt war ich, ich war in einer Wüste ja, jetzt, jetzt müsste ich
eigentlich das Genshin Placement machen, könnte ich sagen, dass ich schon, übrigens wisst
ihr was ich geil fand, irgendein Typ hat mich gefragt unter dem Video, was ist mein Lieblings,
was ist dein Lieblings Genshin Waifu, da hab ich geschrieben Venti und irgendwie hat keiner
gecheckt, sind keine Genshin Kenner hier am Start, wenn man immer nur die neuesten 3
Maps spielt, macht das Spiel echt korrekt, also das hier ist gut mit den neuen Maps und
wenn Bad Company 2 Maps kommen, dann ist das auch ziemlich nice, aber anscheinend kommen
ja, oh Gott, die Palme man, aber anscheinend kommen ja sehr selten Bad Company 2 Maps,
Venti ist das nicht, endlich war einer das gecheckt hat, alter, Venti ist ein Typ, genau,
gab es wenigstens genug Kohle, weiß nicht ob ich irgendwas unterschrieben hab, dass ich
nicht erzählen darf, aber ja, sonst hätte ich es doch nicht gemacht, sonst hätte ich
das nicht gemacht, gäbe es nicht genug Kohle, glaub wir müssen mal zur B rüber, erinnern
euch noch dran, es gab Zeiten, da kamen Elite Soldaten über so einen Zaun drüber, was,
was ist da drüben, Legacy Feature, alles, alles Legacy Feature, also anscheinend haben
die sich jetzt ein bisschen auf A eingeschossen, wie es aussieht, das hast du dir so gedacht
Pantsman hier, muss mich mal kurz verdrücken, dass der Panzer mich nicht platt macht, hallo,
hallo, Panzer, mal gucken ob da einer rausspringt, komm, komm wir rennen jetzt hinterher und
hoffen, dass da einer respawnen und rausspringt, da oben sind sie schon, ich seh sie, ich seh
sie, oh, oh, das war blöd, da waren sie schon, ich hab sie eben schon da drüben gesehen
guck mal, guck mal, fuck, okay, okay, Prager, Prager Chat, Prager, Prager, Prager, Prager,
Prager, easy und jetzt ist B am Schall, komm, YOLO, YOLO Time, nee, woah, woah, woah, dachte
ich, Alter, Diffuse Champ und er drückt weiter E, Massive, oh, oh, ich hab die Waffe geswischt,
ja, vielleicht gewinnt, oh nee, da ist ein Heli drüber, ich spawn lieber wieder rein,
bis ich, ich glaub, wiederbelebt ist, wie, da war, Alter, eben waren noch Leute, Keg
Wade, eben waren noch 3 Leute um mich herum, sind die gerade alle verreckt, wahrscheinlich,
das ist halt an Our Class, generell an vielen der unüberarbeitenden klassischen Maps richtig
pepega, diese ganze Helistellscheiße da, weiß ich genau von wo er auf mich geschossen
wird, wie, Moment, wir haben gewonnen, easy, easy, dazu kann ich nur sagen, Sekunde, muss
jetzt immer umschalten, dass ich Emotes einplanten kann, das ist auch ziemlich dumm, weil halt
Game Fullscreen, gibt übrigens keine Cringe Ansagesprüche mehr, invite, klar, wenn du
mitspielen willst, ich invite dich, continue, übrigens, eins hab ich auch noch nicht so
ganz gecheckt, wenn ich jetzt sage, return to menu, dann flieg ich aus dem Matchmaking,
wenn ich einfach nur mir diesen Bildschirm hier für 20 Sekunden angucke, dann gehts
weiter, was natürlich ziemlich bescheuert ist, weil es passiert einfach 20 Sekunden
lang nix, und, ja, und übrigens, zu anlocken gibt's nicht wirklich auch was und man kann
sich Dinge nicht mal angucken, die man hier anlocken kann, was jetzt, noch mal Our Class,
okay, Fatal und Serious Max, ich invite euch, noch mal Our Class, okay, wir machen den,
wir machen die Attack, komm, wir machen eine Our Class Attack Runde, ich invite euch gerade
mal im Ladebildschirm, Squad Voice Chat Active, sollte eigentlich nicht so sein, kann ich
euch hinzufügen, irgendwie, hm, Social, habt ihr irgendwie einen Plan, kann man hier Leute
hinzufügen, wenn man, ah, Tab, Tab, Social, Fatal ist am Start und Serious Max ist am
Start, alles, hoffentlich funktioniert das jetzt, so, jetzt zeigen wir denen mal hier,
wie durchgerusht wird, kann man, ich hab die Maps so gut wie nie gespielt in Rush, kann
man hier aus so rumlaufen, hab ich auch nicht vorherlich gesagt, weil, naja, Our Class ist
schon so immer grausam und in Rush ist die auch nicht wirklich gut, wobei ich finde,
es ist so gut wie alles besser in Rush, mag daran liegen, dass das mal mit Abstand, Favorite
und Spielmodus ist, komm mal, pass mal auf, Sneaky Stealth, Massive Stealth, komm mal,
die checken es wieder nicht, Kackel, Moment, ist das unten, äh, wait a minute, wo ist
denn das, wo ist denn das, wo ist denn das, muss ich da hier runter, oder wie, Achtung,
lege Champ, lege Champ, versteck, versteck, versteck Champ, in der Ecke, die kommen ja
von da, so, mal kurz den Motion Sensor hin, da ist er schon, der erste, auf, komm um die
Ecke, ich weiß, dass du da stehst, komm um die Ecke, ich mach jetzt die MW2 Taktik,
einfach ab aimen, des Todes, ich hör da was, Achtung, oder auch nicht, pass mal auf, ach,
hier kann man nicht raus, ach, hier kann gar keiner herkommen, nice, nice, nice, kann man
hier durch krabbeln, krabbeln Stealth, komm mal her, durch Krabblors, durch Krabblors, ach,
ebenso, wowowowowow, massive Krabblors, oh, oh, oh oh, hinter mir, Monka Broken Champ,
Richtig am Baschen, so muss das sein.
Okay, retten wird mich hier wahrscheinlich in der Ecke keiner.
Ich lieg ja wirklich komplett, guckt mal hier.
Da geht's, Esther, so muss das sein.
Lege Henne wa unterwegs.
Der M-Com Sound ist übrigens auch doof.
Wir machen Flank, Flankchamp wieder.
Gachibass von der Seite.
Ich hab die Hoffnung, die haben uns noch nicht gecheckt.
Nee, da kann nix herkommen.
Okay, Yolo, direkt raus. Oh, die sehen mich.
Wenn die mich nicht sehen, sind sie richtig hängen geblieben.
Okay.
Richtige PP-Gas.
Oh, das war ziemlich doof.
Ich muss mich kurz verpessen.
Genugtum, Mann.
Lul.
Einfach plopp und weg ist er.
Können wir das komische Ding jetzt mal, please?
Können wir das Teil mal kurz planten?
Und die lege Henne jetzt mal durchziehen?
Aufspringen vor mir runter, Alter.
Die lege Henne.
Auf, gib ihm.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Alter, wie viele sind da hinten?
Nicht die M4, die M16 gibt es zum Unlocken.
Danke, Väter.
Die M16 gibt es zum Unlocken.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Achtung.
Kack.
Lul, Alter.
Streckt doch, please, noch mehr euren...
Alter, jetzt...
Was ist mit denen los?
Oh, weg.
Väter, ich kann dich nicht holen.
Jetzt bist du wieder da.
Achtung.
Hätte funktionieren können.
Moment, wir haben das M-Com immer noch nicht.
Ernsthaft?
Oh, MVP.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz ein Stückchen weg hier.
Das ist ein bisschen zu viel los hier.
Alter.
Oh, ich brenne.
Flame-Champ.
Please, können wir das Ding jetzt einfach mal legen?
Und dann...
Irgendwie gucken, dass es durchgeht.
Oh, nee, oder?
Auf.
Ich brauch deine Waffe. Ah, gut.
Sag mal, warum fliegen...
Ist das verbaggt? Warum geht das nicht?
Warum ist... Ist das M-Com... Ist das M-Com kaputt?
Ich glaube, das M-Com ist defekt.
Leute, das M-Com ist kaputt.
Das ist seit fünf Minuten. Tut es schon...
Tut es schon blinken.
Bugged. Bugged. Nice.
Na, geil. Sehr schön.
Ein buggedes M-Com.
Wo wir wieder dabei sind.
Excellent. Nice. Excellent.
We are running low on troops.
Na ja, gut.
Alter, ist das kaputt wieder, das Game, man.
Ammo. Gib mir Ammo.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
In der Hoffnung...
Wie kann das bitte sein?
Ich finde, das müssten wir jetzt mal in der E-Mail
an den Support in Schweden schreiben.
Und fragen DICE, könnt ihr uns bitte erklären, wie das sein kann?
Und dann antworten die, ach, das wussten wir ja gar nicht.
Aber jetzt, weil der Max uns geschrieben hat
und der Twitch-Chat immer so nett ist bei Max,
jetzt fixen wir das.
Das haben die dann rein uns zu verdanken,
dass das gefixt wird.
990.59.0.
Also, Chat.
Wir schreiben nachher eine Mail an DICE.
Auf Schwedisch.
Dass sie das auch verstehen.
Und wir schreiben Feedback,
so wie man Feedback an DICE schreiben muss.
Nämlich, dass das ein amazing Game ist.
Und wir so much fun haben.
While playing.
And greatest game of the century.
And we are very grateful
for making this game.
So, und man muss DICE,
die bekommen sonst komplett Nervenzusammenbruch,
wenn du gleich anfängst zu flamen.
Also, du musst erstmal übel schleimen.
Das hab ich auch bei diesen Events gesehen.
Sag mal, ist das komplett?
Leute, ist das ne TDM-Runde jetzt?
Wir haben null Tickets. Es ist bugged.
Ich fasse es nicht mal.
Leute, ich zieh uns raus.
28 Kills.
Ich zieh uns raus.
In die Lobby wieder.
Das ist ein endloses Spawn-Rape-TDM
jetzt geworden.
Okay, komm.
Kann man leaven mit dem gesamten Team?
Wisst ihr, ob das die Leute mit rauszieht?
Probieren wir mal. Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Nur solo.
Aber wir haben Royal Lion.
Leute, guckt mal.
Dieses Ding.
Das war natürlich schon mal enorm wichtig,
dass wir da dieses Ding als Freigeschalt.
Next Reward.
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich gar nicht so schlecht.
So social.
Serious Max in Weitem.
Leute, ich kann euch nicht in Weitem.
Ihr müsst rausgehen.
In Weit geht nicht, solange die schon in einer Party drin sind.
Ist auch ein geiles System, oder?
Ach, jetzt ist Endscreen.
Moment, da kann ich ja wieder bei euch reinjoinen.
War ich der bugged?
War ich der verbugged? Weil jetzt, wo ich rausgegangen bin,
ging's wieder.
Ich kann euch übrigens nicht.
Doch, jetzt kann ihr euch joinen.
Ja, join.
Macht mich mal.
Macht mich mal, please leader.
Oder soll ich neu aufmachen?
Ich mach neu auf, Leute.
Leaf Party, oder?
Oder bin ich? Ah, nee, ich bin.
Alles klar, danke.
Fängt an, wenn man...
Was?
Das kommt davon, wenn man anfängt, JavaScript zu mögen.
Der Zusammenhang erschließt sich mir jetzt nicht so ganz.
Ich hätte jetzt eher an so ein Kubernetes-Deployment gedacht.
Guck mal, neuer Kubernetes-Cluster im Hintergrund.
Ungefähr so ordentlich würde der auch aussehen.
Was hältst du von The Finals?
Ich hab letztens einen Trailer zugesehen.
Das sah mir ein bisschen vom Hipster-Style nach Apex aus.
Nach manchen Apex, wir sind so cool, Helden.
Ah, Stranded, die neue Map. Sehr schön.
Die ist wirklich nice im Vergleich zu vielen anderen.
Also, das muss man ihnen lassen.
Ich meine, das ist auch komplette Containermap wieder,
aber das ist echt in Ordnung.
Ist es in der EA-Play-Subscription drin?
Das ist eine gute Frage, weiß ich gar nicht.
Oh, wir verlieren gerade. Nice, GG.
Aber das ist nur erste Base.
Horst. Horst Base.
Pass mal auf jetzt. Sixhead, Sixhead-Play.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es nicht klappt.
Okay, es klappt nicht. Gucken zu viele Gegner schon.
Sixhead.
Alter, ich wurde gerade wieder...
Nee, ich wurde gesniped.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wurde gerade wieder noobtubed.
Aber ich wurde gesniped.
Jawoll, lass mich hier hin.
Ich defende eigentlich nicht.
What the fuck? Nicht so gerne.
Ich bin am liebsten auf Attack bei Rush.
Oh, da muss ich weg. Guck mal, wie viele da uns gegenüberstehen.
Spam, Spam, Spam.
Oh, richtig schön PP-Guard, aber noch erwischt.
Oh, da sniped mir in den Ass-Klai.
Oh, da ist sie wieder.
Oh.
Busy viele.
Okay, respawn. Hier rettet mich eh keiner.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, es gibt wirklich einen schönen Flankweg in dem Schiff.
Falls ich da irgendwie hinkomme.
Oh, jetzt weg.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ihr killt mich jetzt nicht.
Es gibt einen schönen Flankweg und ich weine nicht übers Dach,
sondern hintenrum.
Durchs Hintertürchen sozusagen.
Oh, es laggt.
Es laggt. Es laggt, krass.
Es laggt, krass. Ich kann nicht mehr aufhören zu schießen.
Es laggt.
Hier.
Hier ist, hier ist der beste.
Also das muss ich euch dann als Attacker zeigen.
Hier ist der beste Flankweg, Leute. Hier rum.
PP-Guard.
Massive PP-Guard.
Kackel.
Ich hoffe, die haben mich noch nicht gesehen.
Doch, die haben mich gesehen.
Okay, ich muss mal ins Schiff rein, da drehe ich schon die Action.
Und zack.
Also der Flankweg ist außen rechts wirklich am besten.
Da kannst du nämlich, wenn du außen rumflankst,
hier kommst du nämlich nicht hoch, nur als Website kannst du hier rein
oder ganz außen durch, was die wahrscheinlich gemacht haben.
Ich hoffe, es emt keiner dahin.
So.
Da müssen wir jetzt trotzdem mal kurz gucken.
Auf Bravo-Objective.
Da gibt's, das ist nämlich, das ist nämlich der,
quasi der Kubernetes-Cluster des Schiffes hier.
Alter, das sitzt da oben drauf mit seiner Sentry-Gun.
Sonst hat er nichts Besseres zu tun, als sich da oben mit der Sentry-Gun hinzukampen.
So jetzt, ich wollte die eigentlich von hinten ein bisschen aufrollen.
So, wir gehen auf die andere Seite.
Weil da kann man runtertroppen.
Das ist der Flankweg.
Alter, das laggt, oder?
Ich droppe, ich droppe Frames.
Oder?
Droppe ich Frames?
Oder sieht das bei mir nur in der Vorschau so aus?
Oh, das war blöd.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo die Gegner sind.
Ich schmeiße mal hier meinen Motion.
Motion, ach, sind die da?
Das scheint nix mehr zu sein.
Ja, da oben rettet mich niemand.
Installier mal Optifine.
Ist Optifine nicht dieses Minecraft-Shader-Mod?
Oh, oh, Achtung, Play, Play, Massive.
Massive Fire-IQ-Play.
Pass mal auf.
Und jetzt, und jetzt.
Nee, hat nicht funktioniert.
Ah man.
Hat's ja mal probiert.
Und Pepega.
Wir brauchen ein Pepega-Aim, Ausrufezeichen, Bot-Command.
Warte mal, es ist mir gerade zu viel.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Boomer, Boomer, alt.
Massive-Aim.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Krass, krass ist das Scheibenwischer-Aim.
Überhaupt.
Oh, so dumm, Alter.
Ich treff nichts.
Ich bin so schlecht.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Aber.
Was wollte ich sagen?
Ah, mit 38.
Ist das okay?
Vielleicht landet es ja im Game Pass.
Ich hab eh keine Ahnung, Leute.
Warum ist das überhaupt nicht im Game Pass?
So ganz ein.
Oder nicht im Game Pass.
Im EA.
In diesem EA-Abo.
Wo ist er hin?
Der ist doch zur anderen Bombe durchgerannt.
Der Dude, oder?
Der ist doch garantiert zu A durchgerannt, Leute.
Gleich blinkt A.
Nee, da liegt er.
Da geht an A doch nichts.
EA.
Ach, der ist...
Ja, aber das ist halt...
Es ist halt richtig blöd, dass das nicht drin ist.
Warum ist das nicht drin?
Weil dann hätte das ein bisschen bessere Spielerzahlen.
War das der Gegner?
Auf der anderen Seite ist auch einer.
Alter, ich hab vier gedrückt.
Der heilt sich einfach nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Der hat sich einfach nicht geheilt.
Pass auf, wir machen jetzt flank.
Noobtubed.
Von der Seite genoobtubed.
Warum ist das eine Challenge?
Ah, shit.
Was dieses EA-Abo ist, auch im Game Pass kann alle EA-Games zocken bis auf 2042.
Ja, aber warum ist es nicht drin?
Ist ja die Frage.
Alter.
Ich sag mal, ich werd nur noch genoobtubed gerade.
Die machen alle diese dämliche M16-Challenge, Mann.
Was ist das?
Noobtubed tot, Noobtubed tot.
Mach das jetzt auch gleich.
BF20 verkauft doch sowieso niemand blind.
Sag mal, es ruckelt doch ein bisschen, oder?
Bin ich jetzt total...
Ich seh das gerade auf meinem Vorschau-Bildschirm, aber es ist keine Frames, Mist und nichts.
Ich glaub, das liegt an meinem Vorschau-Rechner, der einfach nicht klarkommt damit.
Ich muss gleich mal auf dem Handyprobe gucken.
Passt mal auf.
Hallo? Nee, hier geht's noch nicht rauf.
Alles gut? Dann ist es nur die Vorschau, die ruckelt.
Was zum...
Das ist über Range nicht so geil.
Massive Aim geht ab.
So, wir kriegen jetzt mal diesen Motion-Sensor.
Das wackelt aber auch ganz schön.
Ich seh' eher richtig.
Er muss mir ein bisschen Mühe geben.
Die kommen nicht wirklich auf den Spot gerade. Guck mal, da oben wollte einer fliegen.
Ich hör' da unten was laufen.
Ah, weggeschneibert.
In der letzten Base, muss ich sagen, gehen wir mal auf Submachine Gun.
Weil da ist ziemlich, meistens zumindest ziemlich Close Quarter lastig.
Der Serious Markster macht's alle alleine weg.
Gucken, ob die überhaupt vorwärts kommen, soweit dass sie in der Base mal landen.
Nope.
In the Corp.
Der will mich Snoop tupen, Alter, habt ihr's gesehen?
Habt ihr's gehört? Der hat direkt rum runter genug tupen.
Oder von hinten kommt noch mehr.
Ja, geil.
Alter, die sind ja dran.
Nein, schießt mir nicht in Bobbes.
Container Field, ja, ist so.
Ist so.
Das Spiel ist wirklich...
Wenn ihnen nix eingefallen ist, was sie wohin klatschen können, dann haben sie einfach gesagt, ja, wir machen so ein paar Absperrungshütchen.
Oder wir machen ein paar Steine, oder wir machen ein paar LKWs, oder wir machen Container, oder wir machen LKWs mit Container obendrauf.
Achtung.
Lege Henne.
Nice.
Oh, da war was.
Ach, Moment, ich hab ne Frag da, nee.
Entschärfungs-Cham, nein.
Mehr Container, oh oh.
Das ist mir ein bisschen viel los hier.
Oh oh, oh oh.
Fuck, wie komm ich denn wieder runter?
Gar nicht.
Hast du schon mal Warzone ausprobiert?
Ja, hab ich.
Ich hab sogar relativ, also für meine Verhältnisse relativ viel Warzone probiert.
Oh oh.
Shit, Alter.
Ich hab sogar schon relativ viel Warzone für meine Verhältnisse ausprobiert irgendwie.
Jetzt hab ich ja 120 Stunden oder so.
Aber ich komm, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie ist Battle Royale einfach nicht meins.
Nicht nur Container, warum immer wieder eine Map mit einem Schiff?
Wahrscheinlich weil die schon Assets hatten in Form von Containern und sich gedacht haben, okay, was können wir für ne Map bauen, wo Container möglichst natürlich wirken?
Und da haben sie gesagt, aha, wir machen einfach eine Schiffsmap mit Containerschiffen.
Meine Güte.
Haben wir entschärft?
Oh, Pog.
Jetzt muss ich mich vielleicht mal anstrengen zur Abwechslung.
Ach, da ist er.
Meine Güte.
Ich hab überhaupt keine Orientierung mehr gerade.
Hinter mir.
Ah, Shit.
Die Füße gesehen.
Wolle, danke für den Sam.
Könnte es mit Konsolen zusammenhängen, so ein Grafikthema?
Nee.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal Spiele auf der Xbox 360 an.
Die hatten teilweise vielfältigere und schönere.
Da war doch ein Gegner gerade.
Ah, wo geht's lang?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Vielfältigere und schönere Sachen als dieses Game.
Ist mir gerade zu...
Ah, Shit. Ich dachte, man kann irgendwie vorbeispringen.
Aber A, A geht.
In Combat, in Combat.
Schnell rein.
Wo sind wir denn hier überhaupt?
Können wir die in den S bashen?
Die spawnen doch da hinten irgendwo.
Da kommt was rein geflogen.
Fuck.
Ich wusste nicht ob oben oder unten.
Sieht schlecht aus als Battlefield 3 damals.
Ja, das liegt mit daran, dass die Beleuchtung so komisch ist.
Die Beleuchtung ist komisch und...
Easy.
Easy win.
Die Beleuchtung ist komisch.
Der Detailgrad ist komisch.
Die Vielfalt der Sachen auf der Maps sind auch komisch.
Ich mein, muss ich mal angucken.
Grand Bazaar.
Weil viel rudimentärer kann eine Map eigentlich nicht sein.
Ein paar Straßen, Beton, Wände, eine Brücke oder so.
Aber Grand Bazaar hatte allein schon auch, dass es ein bisschen Nebel gegeben hat.
Nasse Straßen teilweise.
Hat irgendwie lebendiger gewirkt als die 2042 Maps.
Also Größe ist ja wirklich nicht alles.
Die Maps mögen zwar groß sein, aber...
Was hab ich von großen Maps, wenn sie einfach nur langweilig sind?
Wie laufen die Runden?
Eigentlich recht gut.
Die Runde war hardcore pepega.
Aber muss auch mal sein.
Wie haben wir da irgendwas progresst?
Und haben jetzt, was haben wir...
Leute wisst ihr, guck mal.
Jedes andere Game, was ich kenne mit einem Battle Pass.
Da kannst du dann, wenn du was unlocked hast, das irgendwie anklicken.
Und dir angucken und drehen und sagen, ich will es gleich equippen und sowas.
Ah, will gescheite Map.
Pog.
Was, Max, irgendwelche Tipps für AP2?
Was ist AP2?
Ach, für den Physik, keine Ahnung.
Ach, das ist Abschlussprüfung 2.
Meine Güte, mehr Abkürzungen, please.
Moin, Lordkiller.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich hab irgendwas übersehen.
Hast du schon mal World War 3 gespielt?
Ja, sogar im Stream.
Das macht tatsächlich Bock.
Aber es ist halt mit russischem Anti-Cheat und sonstwie Dingern.
Und es ist ewig nicht rausgekommen.
Ich hab's mittlerweile wieder deinstalliert.
Lobby Bug, das braucht noch.
Das braucht noch.
Muss noch Leute suchen.
Dann müsste es eigentlich auch losgehen.
Nee, Lobby ist wirklich bugged.
Versuch mal, oh ja, doch, jetzt geht es doch los.
Moment, Serious Max ist tatsächlich raus.
Was, Social?
Wo ist er?
Nee, du bist ergeblich in der Party drinnen.
Joins bei dir jetzt.
Wenn nicht, geh mal aus der Party raus.
Und ich invite dich wieder.
Oh nee, Bots?
Bots.
Okay, ich geh jetzt auf die erste Base.
Und wenn es bis dahin nicht aufgefüllt ist mit echten Spielern.
Alter, ich fahr mit Bots.
Guckt euch das an.
Guckt euch mal, wie bescheuert dieses Aim immer noch ist.
Ich hab dich gerade invite, geht's nicht?
Nee, Leute, wir müssen raus.
Das ist Bot-Lobby.
Oh man, Battlefield, please.
Komm mal, jetzt bekriegen sich hier die Bots.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Von STPRKSCOSAI wurde ich gewonshotted.
Okay, Leute, ich mach die Lobby neu auf.
Und dann machen wir es anders.
Ich joine in ein Game und dann invite ich euch.
Weil irgendwie scheint es zu backen, wenn man mit mehreren Leuten...
Das ist... muss ich echt mal überlegen.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich fail, oder?
Das ist ein Jahr nach Release, das immer noch so krass rumbackt mit Lobbys.
Ich hab die letzten zwei Tage solo gespielt, überhaupt keine Probleme.
Ich bin weder in verbackten Lobbys gewesen, noch sonst was.
Aber sobald ich jetzt mit, ja, hier, mit Premade Lobby spiele, backt jede zweite Runde.
Discarded.
Ich hätte gerne die ordentlichen Maps, sowas wie...
Orbital ist beispielsweise ganz nice jetzt auf Rush oder die...
Die von Season 1, die Map ist auf Rush auch ganz gut.
Oder die BC2 Maps und sowas.
So, invite kommt, Social.
Ihr seid schon bei mir drinne, oder wie?
Ach, jetzt hab ich die Lobby doch mitgenommen.
Okay.
Na gut.
Omega-Lul.
Oh, links ist...
Ey, Grenadelauncher. Grenadelauncher.
Keck.
Oh, da sind ganz schön viele. Also, die haben sich da aber ganz schön einverbarrikadiert in diesem Haus.
Das ist, glaub ich, Lost.
Das...
Ja, na, das geht noch nicht als Spawn-Rape durch. Spawn-Rape ist, wenn jetzt hier einer dahinter stehen würde.
Übrigens, B ist, finde ich, nahezu nicht gescheit defendbar.
Aber trotzdem. Wir probieren das mal.
Indem wir...
Oh, da vorne ist ein UAV. Äh, nicht ein UAV, Leute. Ich kann nicht mehr richtig reden.
Ihr wisst schon, was ich meine, gell?
Und der Panzer, das...
Oh, oh, ganz dumm gewesen, da runterzuspringen. Ganz dumm.
Mein Gott. Ich wollte aufs Dach und nicht durchs Fenster.
Letztendlich war es ganz gut, dass ich durchs Fenster... Ich wollte nicht durchs Fenster.
Kommt da nicht rein, Leute. Da ist alles voll.
Nochmal aufs Dach. Dach war gut.
So. Die sind ziemlich...
Was?
Warum ist da grad nicht gestorben? Lul. Da vorne?
Ha! Lul!
So, jetzt stürmen sie. Wir hätten die in diesem komischen...
Äh, in dieser komischen Fabrikhalle einfach verschimmeln lassen sollen. Jetzt...
Oh! Jetzt stürmen sie hier auf B drauf. Aber sie haben nur noch 35 Tickets.
Auf Flank-Action. Muni...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo. Ist da oben was?
Auto?
Kurz hier durch... kurz hier durchstellen.
Oh! Oh!
L.A...
L.A.V. am M-Com. Das ist schlecht.
Oh, was geht denn mit dem ab?
Wie Belfig spielt er.
Wo ist er?
GG Eats. Fuck.
Naja, immerhin cooler Run gewesen.
Bisschen was weggeflankt.
Oh, nee! Du wolltest mich... Leute, sorry, ich release zu schnell.
Ähm, nennt man das im Spiel überhaupt so? Nein, ich respawne zu schnell, meine ich.
Releasen, das ist so MMO-Sprache von 2000.
Ich bin jetzt nicht gewohnt, dass ich mit Leuten zusammenspiele.
Der Fabian hätte es verstanden, wenn ich gesagt hätte, releasen.
Lebt der Dude noch?
Ja, aber er hat gelebt.
Chat, was denkt ihr bis jetzt über das Game, was ihr bis jetzt gesehen habt?
Meint ihr, sie haben in einem Jahr genug geschafft, dass ich das, dass ich das quasi...
...bisschen seinen schlechten Ruf wieder wegmachen kann?
Okay, chat nicht.
Oh, nee.
Ha! So nicht, Kollege! Diffuse-Cham!
Easy!
Die Specialists müssen noch entfernt werden. Sagt ihr, die werden nicht entfernt?
Die werden nicht entfernt.
Ich dachte mir am Anfang auch gar nicht, dass das so...
Okay, muss ich anders erzählen.
Also, der Typ sieht aus wie direkt aus Black Ops 3.
Sieht aus wie der eine Typ aus Black Ops 3, Multiplayer.
Also, erst mal war ich kein Fan von Specialists am Anfang.
Als ich mir dann aber ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht hab, muss ich sagen,
so schlecht, wie es geredet wurde, und jetzt auch im Nachhinein immer noch,
fand ich es am Anfang gar nicht.
Ich fand den Ansatz mit Specialists prinzipiell nicht verkehrt.
Erstens, weil es eine gute Monetarisierungsmöglichkeit gibt.
Klar, man kann sagen, Monetarisierung, who cares?
Aber irgendwie musste halt, wenn ihr das Spiel gefällt,
hoffen, dass es sich langfristig lohnt für den Hersteller.
Ich dachte mir, das ist eine gute Monetarisierungsmöglichkeit.
Und nachdem ich dachte, dass die Specialists quasi nur Verfeinerungen
der bestehenden Klassen sind, was sie streng genommen ja auch sind,
also die Specialists sind ja nach wie vor Engineer, Medic, Recon, Assault,
aber das, sag mal mal, das Ursprungskit schimmert da halt nicht mehr durch.
Ich dachte ursprünglich halt, dass beispielsweise McKay, jeder Typ,
mit dem Enterhaken, den ich spiele, das ist ein Engineer mit einem Enterhaken.
Also ich hab im Endeffekt dann mein Engineer-Kit
und hab dann halt ein festes zweites Gadget.
Ja, so ist es irgendwie auch, aber du kannst trotzdem ja mit jeder Klasse
alles wählen und dementsprechend auch als Engineer, Medipacks und sonst was,
das ergibt dann wieder keinen Sinn.
Die Wingsuit-Tante ist auch tatsächlich zu extrem gewesen.
Die wurde, glaub ich, genervt mittlerweile und finde ich sogar ganz sinnvoll,
in der sie, glaube ich, ich hab die bis jetzt noch gar nicht mal ausprobiert,
die zweite Granate weggemacht haben.
Das fand ich ganz gut, weil gerade die Frag Grenade,
also die Fragmentation Grenade, die zu spammen war ziemlich OP.
Du konntest ja dann auch noch einen Motion-Sensor oder irgendwas werfen
oder noch Smoke dabei.
Bringen die irgendwann einen Server-Browser rein?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Okay, okay, okay, ich weiß, manche sagen jetzt wieder,
Max, es gibt doch einen Server-Browser.
Na ja, Leute, es gibt Portal, es gibt den Portal-Browser,
aber da ist halt keiner drinne.
Okay, zu viel PP gar nicht, aber hätte klappen können.
Hätte klappen können.
Alter, geh doch mal aus deinem Loch da hinten raus, man.
Geh aus deinem Loch.
Ich geh da jetzt runter.
Piss dich, Aldo.
360 Noscope.
Will ich?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, der ist vorbeigehüpft, macht nichts.
360 Noscoped, fuck.
Aber wir kriegen das.
Zu viel Legacy-Feature.
So, während die jetzt...
Oh, da neben ist total viel, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Alter, ich wäre hier gerade geaimt von...
Ich muss weg.
Und tschüss.
Bunny hoppen, weg hier.
Alter, Monka.
Okay, wir machen jetzt das Play.
Fuck, die sind alle da.
Und shooten wir in der Ass.
Vielleicht.
Achtung.
So.
Oh, shit.
Fast dran gewesen.
Der Sniper-Typ, man.
Der mit der Gold-Sniper, der ist richtig gut.
Also, es können keine Cheater sein.
Lasst euch das mal gesagt sein.
Es gibt keine Cheats mehr für das Game.
Weil die ganzen Cheat-Entwickler die Arbeit und den Support eingestellt haben an Battlefield 22.
Da wollte ich nicht hin.
Nein.
Nice.
Danke.
Danke für dieses Precise-Movement-Spiel.
Ich wollte in den Container rein.
Lohnt sich nicht.
Ja, die haben die Cheat-Entwicklung eingestellt.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, oder?
Leute.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, der hat noch mehr PP geaimt als ich.
Stammy nicht gekillt hat.
Lul.
Ach, man.
Warum drehen die sich auch im falschen Moment um?
Die Runde läuft da gar nicht.
So, nice, nice, nice.
Reinsporn.
Und direkt aufs Dach.
Mensch.
Bleibt mal da.
Was?
WTF?
Das waren gerade vier Schüsse oder so voll im Kopf.
Aber nein.
Bleiben stehen.
Der Ivan.
Ivan.
Ivan 0265.
Der macht es jetzt easy.
Ivan owned.
Ivan Pogge jammed.
Ey, warum hat der Heal abgebrochen?
The fuck?
Das hat einfach der Heal abgebrochen.
Ey, der Schneibermann, der Typ, der fuckt mich ultra ab.
Der hat mich jetzt schon fünf Mal gesniped.
Ich glaube jeder der diese Runde war der Schneibermann.
Ah ja.
Au, au.
Jetzt wird es aber kritisch hier gerade.
Gleich geht es auf.
Ist der Schneibermann noch da?
Alter, das Movement, Mann.
Wo ist denn der?
Ach, da.
Das moves mich da, wo ich überhaupt nicht hinmoven wollte.
Hast du dir Finals angesehen?
Leute, ich muss, warte mal, ich muss mir mal kurz den Trailer davon.
The Finals Trailer.
Das müssen wir uns gleich angucken.
Ich bilde mir ein, als ich das gesehen habe.
Das ist das von Embark Studios oder wie die heißen.
Also die, die früher mal DICE waren.
Also viele von DICE.
Okay.
P-P-P-P-Pegger.
Ach, das ist der Typ mit der.
Der Achter.
So geht das aber nicht.
Der Rush Master muss wieder zuschlagen.
Besser als der Coin Master.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ein Nebel.
Nebel, stell es.
Hoffentlich komme ich schnell rüber, bevor die mich erwischen.
Oh, nice.
Ich werde.
Ne, Nebel.
Ne, neblos.
Und jetzt machen wir da vorne noch einen Motion Sensor.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Easy.
Auf geht's.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also hier durchzukommen ist schwierig.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh.
Huge Rats.
Huge.
Oh, falsche Richtung.
Huge Massive Rats.
Okay.
Achtung, da ist noch einer.
Ich habe den Schatten gesehen.
Fuck.
Fast.
Fast, Leute.
Jawoll.
Alle weg.
Rushed rein.
Vielleicht kriegt noch jemand einen Rats raus.
Massive Porge.
Die Map ist richtig mies.
Ich spekuliere ja ehrlich gesagt drauf, dass es vielleicht als nächstes wieder eine der
guten Maps gibt.
Komm, wir düsen mal hier mal dahin.
Spawns bei mir rein.
Was macht denn der da?
Wie?
Jetzt gib ihm.
Alter.
Also hier übers Flache zu kommen ist halt echt, da kann an jeder Ecke einer sitzen.
Ziemlich rakewürdig.
Okay, wir müssen das anders angehen.
Wir müssen das anders angehen.
Wir müssen den Stellmodus aktivieren.
Warten wir mal.
Warten wir mal bis da, bis da, bis da.
Oder vom Sch...
Leute.
Sixhead.
Pass mal auf.
Haha.
Aber immerhin.
Hey.
Es hätte funktionieren können.
Ja, geil.
Da stehen sie mit der Gatling-Gun am Stink... und aimen alles ab.
Was willst du da bitteschön machen?
Nice, nice.
Spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn.
Da ist ein Gegner.
Okay.
Ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht resten, sorry, dass wir uns nicht.
Hier, Motion Sensor, Motion Sensor, dass wir sehen, wenn was abgeht.
Oh, da ist einer dran an B, fuck.
Nice, wir haben ihn, okay.
So, der erste Ansturm müsste jetzt ja eigentlich weg sein.
Bam, und jetzt, wenn sie alle herrennen.
Fuck.
Okay, Yolo.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt oder nie, jetzt oder in 26 Tickets noch.
Ich sehe da nichts, ich sehe da nichts.
Da hinten ist was.
Achtung, Achtung, gib ihm, obendrauf muss ich, obendrauf, nein, nein, oh shit.
Du kommst hier nicht durch, das ist so offen und so flach.
Ich mein, okay, mehr als probieren, mehr als probieren geht nicht.
Oh shit.
Oh, lege Hände.
Jawoll, Prager, wir haben es.
Meine Güte, what the fuck.
Was ein Act.
Ach shit, hätte ich weiter im 1,5 bleiben sollen.
Was ein Act, Alter, das war ja der Grind.
Alter, wie viele wollen wir denn noch killen lassen?
Killer Elite, Mann, guckt euch mal an, der out das ganze Team aus dieser Ecke.
Killer Elite, Mensch.
Ich hab ihn noch nicht mal, ah, nice, ich hab ihn, okay.
Geht das so?
Nope, nope, oh, hier war es, wo sind wir denn hier jetzt gelandet?
Bringt das hier was?
Eher nicht, oder?
Egal.
Das hat er sich so nicht vorgestellt.
Alter, Battlefield, come on.
Please, funktionier mal.
Ich will da rauf.
Nee, da geht es auch nicht hoch.
Wird ja immer besser hier.
Wir haben die Base eingenommen, bis ich es mal irgendwann auf das Schiff oben drauf geschafft habe.
Achtung, Massive.
Lege Henne.
Nice Spot, nice Spot.
Da ist einer dran.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das war es wert.
Jetzt müssen die Leute nur noch runrushen und wir haben es.
Leute, es sind so viele, ihr müsst einfach nur das Objective, oh, ich werde sogar gerass.
Massive Pog.
So ist das cool.
So mag ich das.
Wenn wir Glück haben.
Geht schon aus.
Ich habe das jetzt einfach ab, egal was passiert.
Shit.
Alter, okay, mehr geht nicht.
Mehr geht nicht.
Lege Henne.
Aber wir haben uns hier gut eingenistet.
Wir haben viel respawn, wir haben da...
Mit was schieße ich da überhaupt?
Ach nee, das ist Granate.
Ich check die Fahrzeuge gerade nicht.
War das ein Spotter?
War das eine Spotter Position, in der ich war oder?
Nice.
Oh, ich dachte, es ist vorbei.
Ich dachte, es ist vorbei.
Was haltet ihr von WW3?
Okay, Leute, das ist jetzt die fünfte Frage im Stream.
Sollen wir das demnächst nochmal streamen, WW3?
Ich meine, ich will mir keinen Mail.ru Anti-Cheat installieren, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Aber vielleicht...
Ich habe gehört, die haben Mail.ru Anti-Cheat rausgeschmissen.
Und jetzt ist es Mail.China Anti-Cheat.
Es wird wahrscheinlich kein besserer Anti-Cheat.
Monka?
Wo sind wir?
Oh!
Grapple in place.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Die, die, die, die...
Ich kriege kein Wort mehr raus.
Die Direction, aus der man beschossen wird, die Anzeige, ist oftmals auch nicht...
So ganz...
Patel, ich komme.
Oh nein, ich komme nicht.
Nice.
Guter Ress.
Retz.
Geretzt.
Hände, Hände, Hände, Hände, Hände.
Was?
Oh, wo kamen der Typ jetzt noch her?
Oben alles ausgeräuchert und...
Der Shotgun-Typ ist da noch.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Der Shotgun, man.
Nice, nice, nice, nice... Ah, shit.
Okay. Vielleicht haben wir noch ein paar Fahrzeuge hier zu bieten.
Der FinalStreet als Battlefield-König...
Ganz ehrlich, nur dass es von ehemaligen DICE-Entwicklern ist...
Bin mir da gerne zu sicher. Komm, wir gehen zu B.
Ich mein, FinalStreet sieht so über...
...überhaupt nicht aus wie Battlefield.
Und auch alles, was ich gesehen hab, sah auch nicht aus, als spielte es sich wie Battlefield.
Weird. Weird.
Ha, geckl.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Side Step, Side Step.
AD, AD. Das hab ich in Overwatch gelernt. Einfach möglichst viel AD, AD spammen. Und dann ist alles gut.
AD, AD spammen.
Ich hab, ich hör den neben mir.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Stell's, Stell's Champ.
Fuck.
Ah, wusste ich, dass da noch einer liegt.
Keine Chance, aber es sind viele Leute von unserem Team ran.
Bestimmt doch Overwatch 2, stimmt, das hab ich komplett vergessen.
Overwatch 2 kommt ja am Dienstag oder so, gell, Dienstag, Dienstag, oder, ah, ah, 4.
Oktober, Dienstag, ja, lege Hände, komm Leute, defendet, defendet, dreh dich um, dahinter,
glaub, laut dreh dich um, da steht einer in den Eck, Alter, White Angel, geh ran, Alter,
geh ran, MonkaS, Alter, die sind 20 Sekunden aneinander vorbeigelaufen.
Ich, ich blick hier nicht, ist zu viel, ist zu viel los, das ist, Boomer, Boomer, müde,
es ist spät, ich blick nicht mehr durch, Leute, zu viel, auf einmal gerade, aber wir sollten
A, oh nee, da geht gerade einer ran an A und Diffused, nein, der Diffused, der Diffused,
ich seh's, nein, wir haben's, sehr gut, ok, wisst ihr was, solange die da sind, einfach
YOLO, ach, wir können noch gar nicht, shit, aber jetzt, 5 Sekunden und auf geht's, Abfahrt,
gutes Alter, durch, Charlie Mike, was genau ist Charlie Mike, Oscar Mike kenn ich noch,
Oscar Mike ist on the move, das kenn ich noch aus MW2, was ist, was ist Charlie Mike, wer
hat das, wer hat das Military Speak drauf, Alter, was ein, was ein mega schlechtes Aim
von mir gerade, wir gucken uns gleich den, den Finals Trailer an, Max, bleib mal oben,
dass ich, dass ich bei dir spawnen kann, falls es geht, sehr schön, nice, Sixhead Team hier
am Start, so mag ich das, Hi IQ, wo sind denn überhaupt die M-Coms hier, ok, Achtung, Achtung,
passt mal auf, nein, so war das nicht geplant, ich wollte von oben auf das M-Com springen
und mich dann ranziehen mit dem, mit dem Enterhaken, weil das macht lustigerweise, wenn man sich
von oben nach unten zieht, keinerlei Falldamage, ach so, vielleicht soll ich einfach am spawn,
spawnen, oh nee, defused, ok, jetzt müssen wir das auch theoretisch nur ab aimen und während
die da rüber rennen, können wir doch eigentlich auf B, komm, ich probier's mal, ah ja, sieht
cool aus, sieht cool aus, sieht cool aus, lege Henne, lege Henne, null, passt mal auf, wenn
mich hier keiner sieht, werde ich die alle bashen, die B entschärfen wollen, Camp, Camp
time, aber es will glaube ich gar keiner B, entschärfen kann das sein, die denken sich,
nope, B muss not defused werden, easy, win, lege Henne, 116, easy, 38, Hawk, so mag ich
das, out positioned, out six headed, outstanding performance Leute, da habt ihr's, ja, top
1% strat, outstanding performance, 6 mcom armed, hä, ach guck mal 6 armed, 3 destroyed, massive,
immortal strat, oder wie heißt der höchste rang in, in Valorant, war das nicht immortal
oder war Valorant der höchste rang in Valorant, nee immortal ist es in dota, in dota ist es,
in dota ist es immortal oder, nee das hab ich jetzt durcheinander gebracht, warte mal,
nee immortal, ach ja jetzt hab ich durcheinander gebracht, Oscar Mike is on the move, ich weiß
aber was ist Charlie Mike, das war ja die eigentliche Frage, ach continuing mission,
ah, oh, Leute jetzt können wir uns als erstes mal die überarbeitete Kaleidoskop Map angucken,
ich glaube, es gibt jetzt einige Container zu sehen gleich, nur so, nur so eine Vermutung,
nicht ganz sicher aber ich, ich, ich glaube es gibt, Postchamp, ich glaube es gibt ein
paar Container, oh nee ist die Lobby wieder procken, aber das du aktuell ausschließlich
Homeoffice, nein, ich bin auch ein paar Tage in Frankfurt, ich hab übrigens, ich hab übrigens
am Freitag Ärger bekommen, weil ich die letzten drei Wochen nicht oft genug in Frankfurt
war, dabei ist es gar nicht so, dass ich nicht wollte, ich wollte Dienstags hinfahren, zwei
Züge ausgefallen, dann wollte ich Freitags hinfahren, wieder Bahn abfuck, jetzt war ich
halt jeweils da nur einen Tag da, da gab's, da gab's Ärger letztens, dass ich zu wenig
da bin, aber ganz im Ernst, es juckt mich auch nur am Rande, weil, immer so, oh nee
Bot, Bot-Match, Bot-Match, okay, wir warten noch mal kurz, ob das gleich, aber ich bin
da wahrscheinlich eh nicht mehr lange, also insofern, guck jetzt halt, dass ich das so
mache, dass mein Chef nicht so viel Ärger kriegt, demnächst, demnächst kommen wir bei
uns, gibt's auch einen neuen Abteilungsleiter, vielleicht ändert sich bei dem noch was
und ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich bin da eh nicht mehr lange, es sei denn, oh, Peckel,
das waren alles Bots, sonst wär ich tot gewesen, es sei denn, die Firma macht irgendwie noch
mal 180 Grad Kehrtwende, okay, es füllt sich langsam, es füllt sich langsam, bisschen
weniger Bots am Start, Ups, Killa-Elite, ich hab Kommisar-Elite gelesen, Killer-Elite,
ja, okay, es fasst, Bots sind fast alle weg, Alter, ich treff nicht mal nen Bot, man,
wie schlecht kann man sein, wo ist er hin, ist einfach verschwunden, Disarm-Champ, Achtung,
Five-Fed-Time, oh, On-Stream-Job-Suche, wir haben im Stream schon Jobs gesucht und danach
hatte ich drei Angebote, eins, was ich wirklich cool fand, aber wo sich dann leider nix mehr
ergeben hat, da hatte ich einen Probearbeitstag, aber da hatte ich leider Corona und danach
hat sich nix mehr ergeben, oh, ich werd gerest, jutsch, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
Oh oh
Nix, nix wie rauf hier
Äh, by the way, ich bin eigentlich blöd, ich könnte einfach viel öfters die Muni switchen
Ja, also wir haben, wir haben schon Onstream-Stellen-Angebote angeschaut
und wahrscheinlich machen wir das demnächst auch wieder
Nido, danke schön für den Sub
Machen wir das demnächst auch, es ist immer schön zu wissen, was es sonst so, was es so alles gibt
Übrigens, ich halte die ersten zwei Objectives hier für nicht wirklich haltbar
Das Iron Man ist mega viel dominanter als das gesamte Gegner-Team
Hallo, springen! Elite-Soldat
So, jetzt müssen wir hier mal ein bisschen gucken
Es wäre übrigens cool, wenn man immer mit demgleichen spawnen würde und nicht mit dem Backup-Magazin
Der merkt sich immer das letzte, was ziemlich... Ach shit
Ich hab fünf Gegner um mich gehört, dann hab ich mir okay, versuch's mal abzuhauen
Na gut, meine letzte Runde, richtig hardcore geowned
Kann in jeder Runde so sein
Alter, Mensch, lass mich doch mal heilen
Die nächsten M-Coms sind auch einfacher zu defenden in dem Haus hier
Da hinten das, hier, das da ist, glaub ich
Das ist wirklich nice
Da gibt es, da gibt es ein paar richtig six-head-Positions
Zack
Der Kommissar Bert hat mich gekillt
Oh, oh, oh, oh, Max, Max
Max, Pog!
Oh, mein Team ist Six-Header, Alter, guckt's euch an
Guckt's, oh nee, jetzt sind sie alle down, shit
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Max, Max
Max, Pog!
Oh, mein Team ist Six-Header, Alter, guckt's euch an
Guckt's, oh nee, jetzt sind sie alle down, shit
Ich hätte, ich hätte releasen sollen
Stört euch nicht dran, dass ich releasen sag
Das ist, das hab ich mir so angewöhnt
Durch MMOs
Oder durch ein MMO
Für mich gibt es keinen Respawn, für mich gibt es nur releasen
Oh
Achtung
Hi-IQ-Play
Naja, hätte funktionieren können
Hat er mich gearmbrustet? Nee, er hat mich nicht gearmbrustet
Hier gibt's ein richtig geiles Play, was man machen kann
Mal gucken
Ob, ob ich, ob, ob ich dazu komme
Oh nee, die legen schon
Shit
Oh
Ja, ich hab's grad schon Legehennen machen hören
So
Aber anscheinend haben wir's nochmal
Nee, ich glaub, da komm ich nicht zu, aber es gibt hier was wirklich Praktisches
Vielleicht, vielleicht auf A drüben mal gucken
Ja, was wirklich cool ist
Was man nur als McKay, also nur als Enterhaken-Dude machen kann
Killer-Elite am Start
So, hier kann man durchflanken als Attacker
Aha
Nicht gesehen
Wall-Hack
Wo sind denn die überhaupt grade?
Ah, an B, okay
Ja, ist klar
Oh, oh, oh
Ah, shit
Ja, da fliegen sie
Da fliegen sie
Ist da grad einer gespawnt noch bei uns, während wir verreckt sind?
Leute, kaum sind wir verreckt, schon liegt, liegt die Legehenne an B, nee an A
Aber A ist auch schwierig, also A ist tatsächlich
B finde ich persönlich relativ easy zu verteidigen
Ja, please sterben
Danke
Next
Ich dachte, da ist was in der Ecke
Achtung, Yolo-Rez
Mich trifft keiner
So, jetzt ist an B angesagt, oder?
Ich hab hier ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, teilweise den Fluss zu checken
Spiel M, 5A3 oder was anderes macht keinen Sinn zurzeit, doch?
Ja, das Ding streut, aber ich finde die eigentlich ganz nice, weil die so eine hohe Schussrate hat
Jetzt auf die Range, sucks, das ist wohl wahr, ja
Wir müssen mal gucken, dass sie das nicht umlaufen
Ich meine, es ist eh schon relativ easy
Wir müssen uns letztendlich noch leichter machen mit den OP-Waffen der OP-Waffen
Ich glaube, wir haben fast alle Runden gewonnen heute
Enemy spotted
Vielleicht können wir jetzt
Alter Mann
Lohnt es sich Battlefield 2042 zu holen? Nein
Nicht zum Vollpreis
Das einzige, was sich vielleicht lohnt, ist wenn du es irgendwie für 15 Euro oder so kriegst
Ein paar Runden macht das durchaus Bock
Gerade Rush ist sehr nice
Und wenn da ist was geflankt
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung
Achtung
Von wo?
Ah, der hat mich gesehen
Weil das ist eigentlich der Play, den ich euch
Doch alleine macht es auch halbwegs Bock
Denn ich euch zeigen wollte, da oben drauf, ihr könnt Kills farmen ohne Ende
Normalerweise
Auf diesen da
Alter mein PP-Aim, das ist ja immer feierlich
Guckt euch das an
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf
Pass mal auf
Oh shit
Was da los ist
Also alleine finde ich, macht das Game auch nah geil
Macht das Game halbwegs Bock
Aber im Team ist natürlich schon besser
Moment, sind die Dinge immer noch auf dem Dach, die letzten zwei M-Coms?
Die haben nicht wirklich diese kack M-Compose
immer noch ein Jahr nach Release, oder?
Ach man kann da jetzt nicht mehr rüber
Das ist natürlich okay
Okay
Da muss man
Oder kann man jetzt doch wieder rüber?
Nein, kann man nicht
Guckt es euch an
Bisschen hin und her fahren
Nope
Das ist nicht geplant
Darf man hier stehen?
Nee
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Okay, wir räumen von unten auf
Ja, gut
Hat das hier noch irgendeine Tür?
Ich sehe nichts mehr
Nein
Drecksäcke
Ah, shit
Wie, Moment, die sind auf dem Dach
Wir sind hier aufs Dach gekommen wieder
Keck, keck, wait
Hier unten ist alles voll
Shit
Okay, ich glaube das habe ich noch nie gesehen
Dass
Dass hier jemand gewonnen hat
Ja, da hast du recht
Imagine Wagon
Da
Ah, wir hätten in den Heli reingemusst
Da hast du recht, könnte man Map Selection machen
Aber generell Map Selection
Server Browser, sowas ist out
Guckst du dir an, in diesem Game
Nicht dabei, MW2
Nicht dabei, es gibt kaum noch Games
Wo das wirklich
Wo das wirklich der Fall ist
Okay, jetzt
Da hin
Wie kommt man da jetzt drauf?
Killer Elite
Okay, da ist einer auf dem Dach
Jetzt ist gut
Jetzt, jetzt gewinnen wir.
Ease, Ease, Ease.
Ist unser Heli da oben.
Was ist denn das? Was ist denn das?
Ah!
Äh, äh.
Auch, das ist wirklich ein mega sinnloses Feature.
Au! Kannste die... Alter! Heil dich doch mal!
Ich hab fünf Mal auf diesen grumpischen Heel gedrückt. Nope, gibt's nicht.
Chat, was ist besser?
Midi-Pack oder Midi-Pen?
Bei Midi-Kit ist halt das Problem, das hat längeren Reuse, finde ich.
Also hat's definitiv. Nicht nur finde ich, hat auf jeden Fall.
Kann man da durch?
Höheren Reuse.
Aber dafür bricht das...
Shit. Dafür bricht das nicht ab.
Ganz schön viel wieder hier oben los.
Ja, ja, auf, auf, auf.
Leute, ihr habt die Poggers Position.
Direkt am M-Com-Camp, so müssen wir's machen.
So und nicht anders.
Wow!
Oh, oh, oh, lass mich in Ruhe.
Gegner, Gegner.
Also hier geht's grad richtig zur Sache.
Ja, ist mir grad sogar ein bisschen viel Action, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Alter, heil dich doch mal mit diesem komischen Midi-Pen.
Oh, oh.
Shit!
Fuck!
Das ist echt...
Shit! Fuck!
Das wär's Play gewesen.
Ich hätte ihn gekillt, er hat kaum noch Leben gehabt.
Hätte ich defused, ist nur einer.
Okay, ist down, ihr könnt defuse. Easy.
Defused, Leute. Defused, defused, defused, defused.
Puh, das war close.
Das war close.
Wo kommen die überhaupt hier her?
Sind hier Fahrstühle? Ich kenn die Map über...
Sind hier Fahrstühle, wo die hochkommen?
Hier oder so?
Anscheinend.
Easy.
Aber die M-Coms im Ernst, die sind wirklich nicht gut.
Meine Settings, ich hab alles auf Low.
Bis auf Texturen und...
Boah, frag mich.
Weißt ihr gleich. Ich hab aber auch nur 1080 Ti.
Deswegen, und mir sind FPS lieber.
Als bisschen Optik.
Muss aber sagen, das Game sieht auch nicht wahnsinnig geil aus in voller Optik.
Also in vollen Details.
Das ist eigentlich nie eine Augenweide.
Es ist eh beeindruckend.
Wie sie es geschafft haben, dass 2042 so nach Plastik aussieht.
Wohingegen Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 richtig hübsch waren.
Und auch richtig coole Details hatten von Fußspuren im Schnee.
Und Schlamm im Schnee.
Tja, aber nope.
Gibt's nicht.
Können die Hovercraft-Dinger immer noch die Wände hochfahren?
Meines Wissens nach nicht.
Ich glaub, das können die schon ganz lange nicht mehr.
Weil ich das eigentlich cool fand.
So, pass auf Leute.
Jetzt Kaleidoskop-Win.
Ich hab glaub ich noch nie einen Kaleidoskop-Rush-Win gesehen.
Also einen Attacker-Win, nicht einen Rush-Win.
Attacker-Win.
Jetzt kurz, ich zeig dir mal schnell die Settings.
Ach ja, was war's denn jetzt eigentlich?
Midi-Pack?
Midi-Pack oder Midi-Pen?
Weil Midi-Pack hat auch den Vorteil, das heilt andere.
Äh...
Options.
Das ist so verkacktes Menü.
Also guck, ich hab alles auf Low.
Nee, ich hab hier.
Ich hab Texture-Kram auf Medium, Rest alles auf Low, Low, Low.
Und das Einzige, das was ich hier hab, ist auf Ultra.
Was macht das überhaupt?
High-Fidelity-Objects-Amount.
Okay.
Ist die Map neu?
Ja, Kaleidoskop ist neu.
Es gibt zwei neue Maps, Kaleidoskop und Renewal.
Ich mein, man kann nicht erwarten, dass fast ein Jahr nach Release
alle Maps ordentlich überarbeitet sind.
Da müssten sich ja mehr als zwei Mapper in ihrer Freizeit rum kümmern.
Das Midi-Pack heilt das Heilt-Instance, sobald du reingehst.
Dafür hast du ein Reuse-Time von...
Weiß nicht, 10 Sekunden, 15 Sekunden oder so.
Hat die Map Container? Rate mal.
Mr. Moogame, rate mal.
Hat sie oder hat sie nicht?
Pause-Champ.
Kommst du nicht drauf.
Das sind mindestens fünf Kupanetes-Cluster voll hier an Containern.
Und es ist noch nicht mal die containerlastigste Containermap.
Ich glaube, die Map mit den meisten Containern ist tatsächlich die allerneueste.
Hat ein Flugzeug Flügel?
Ja, ist nur die Frage.
Ein oder zwei?
Gibt ja auch welche mit einem.
Und die Lobby wieder verbuggt.
Ich bin noch Level 69.
Ja, das kann man...
Also die Technologie ist eindeutig noch nicht da.
Um Karten in der Lobby on the fly zu updaten.
Ich meine, so eine Karte replacen zwischen zwei Runden.
Was heißt so eine Karte replacen?
Du musst das Overlay, das Zahl-Overlay anpassen.
Okay Leute, ich glaube, ich muss in die Lobby zurück.
Weil es ist procken.
Und dann join ich das Game und ihr solltet ja mitkommen.
Wollen wir nicht noch einen Trailer schauen?
Doch, machen wir.
Jetzt wird erstmal Battlefield weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Braucht kein Mensch? Braucht kein Mensch?
Brauche ich alles nicht.
Next.
Brush.
Seid ihr noch in der Lobby?
Ach, jetzt seid ihr nicht mehr in der Lobby, oder wie?
Oder doch?
Ich checke es nicht.
Ich suche jetzt ein neues Game und invite euch wieder.
Das ist...
Also das Menü ist wirklich hart verka...
Kaleidoskop?
Keckel? Moment.
Da kommen wir doch gerade her.
Das ist bestimmt wieder die kaputtene Map.
Jetzt sind wir wieder in der Lobby.
Oder noch mal Defense.
Wobei noch mal Defense gibt Schlimmeres.
Zumindest haben sie es gefixt.
Könnt ihr euch auch dran erinnern, am Anfang als Rush neu war,
wo du immer nur die gleiche Seite gespielt hast,
wo es nie zwischen Attacker und Defender gewechselt hat?
Das war richtig hängen geblieben.
Wo man sich so gedacht hat,
ihr kriegt nicht mal die Basics der Basics hin.
Oh ne, wir sind Attack...
Ne.
Ne, wir sind...
Wir sind Defender.
Komm, wir spielen mal ein bisschen was anderes.
Komm, wir spielen mal wieder ein bisschen SMG.
Oder Noob Tube.
Ich will den Noob Tube nicht anlocken.
Hab da kein Nerv drauf.
Oh.
Moment, es ist schon zwei.
Moment, es ist schon zweite Base.
Nice Spawn.
MonkaW.
Okay, B ist noch am Start.
Dann machen wir jetzt nice Plays an B.
A ist eh lost.
Oh shit.
Okay...
Fuck, ja, Alter.
Alter, wie viele sind denn da bitte?
Jawoll, Fatal.
Gatchibuzz.
Defuse lieber,
Schatz, mich zu rasen, man.
Disarmed Champ.
Prager, Prager Chat, Prager.
Nice.
Okay, das war close.
Das war close.
Close as fuck, man.
So, Motion Sensor.
Ah shit, den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Oh nee, das ist irgendeine Franzose.
Kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Kein normaler Mensch kann das aussprechen.
Oh Fatal Pog. Ah shit.
Respawn.
Lachs, vielleicht können wir bei dir respawnen.
Die sind da noch drinnen. Achtung, Achtung.
Fatal, ich hol dich schnell.
Pass auf, Pass auf.
Pog, Pog, Pog.
Wieder stirbt nicht.
Keg-Wade.
Ah shit.
Jetzt ist zu viel.
Jetzt ist zu viel auf einmal.
Er wieder.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist verloren.
Keine Chance.
Da kommste nicht mehr rein.
Wir haben alles probiert.
Was ist denn hier?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist denn hier los?
Leben am Limit, Leute.
Leben am Limit.
Das war knapp.
Ich dachte vielleicht kriegen wir noch irgendeinen.
Die Runde kriegen wir aber massiv auf den Sack.
Die ruschen ja durch wie sonst was.
Du hast mich gesehen.
Der denkt jetzt ich komm da, aber ich komm nicht da.
Ich komm da.
Schätz, lebt ihr noch?
Detke.
So einfach A halten, easy.
A halten und freuen und gewinnen.
Ich blicke nicht durch, wo hier die ganzen farscht.
Ah da.
B wird eh nix.
Oh da vorne.
Nein, nicht in A.
Alter, lass mein Bob es in Ruhe.
Ich will nicht von hinten gebankt werden.
Hat er mich voll weggesägt von hinten.
Der Sack.
Egal ob wir Bravo gelostet haben.
A ist das entscheidende.
Oh oh, oh oh.
Die Fuske.
Easy.
Oh.
Alter, der steht da einfach rum.
Kriegt natürlich auch noch was raus.
So, jetzt wirst du echt mal gucken.
Es ist keiner auf dem Dach.
Okay, das ist lost.
Es sei denn die kommen noch mal ran.
Es ist keiner auf dem Dach.
Okay, das ist lost.
Sie kommen noch mal ran.
Lostke.
Ich hab noch nie einen Attacker-Win gesehen.
Leute, auf der Map.
Ich wusste garnicht, dass es geht.
Ohne Scheiß.
Noch nie einen Attacker-Win.
Auf der Map.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, die haben richtig uns weggeknallt.
Oh, Soundbug.
La...
...Pause...
...Euse.
Guck mal, wie kaputt das ist.
Es kommt immer der gleiche Sound.
Das...
Das ist schwarz-weiß.
Guck mal, wie Boris lacht. Habt ihr's gesehen?
Hat sich gefreut.
Container-Field, ja.
Hört der Sound jetzt gar nicht mehr auf?
Ernsthaft?
Leute, jetzt haben wir den gleichen Sound im Menü.
Vom Ende der Runde.
Nein, alles schon, alles gefixt.
Was haben wir anlockt? Man weiß es nicht.
Oh, guck mal, ich hab ne neue Pistole anlockt.
Ist das ne, ist das ne Shotgun-Pistole?
Jetzt.
Okay, jetzt sind wir Attacker und jetzt kriegen wir wahrscheinlich richtig massivst auf den Sack.
Das Gegner-Team war so viel besser.
15 von 237.
P90.
Die müsste man auch mal ausprobieren.
Die müsste man auch mal ausprobieren, ja.
Auf, Game.
Los.
Serious Bugs, bist du rausgeflogen oder ist...
Bug.
Ich entleite dich.
Bald die Runde geladen ist.
Social, wo ist er?
Der Opa, der Opa-Peitscher.
Der nicht.
Attackge.
Probieren wir mal das da aus.
Mal gucken.
Mal schauen.
Ich hab das Gefühl, auf manchen Maps ist man als Attacker schneller da als die Defender an der ersten Base.
Kann das sein?
Geht der in weit wieder nicht?
Okay, das war PP-Gard hoch 10.
Dankeschön, gut, dass ich Teammates hab.
Die mich ressen, wenn ich wieder nix treffe.
So, mal kurz motion-sense.
Unten steht einer, unten steht definitiv.
Auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, schnell, nice.
What?
Please schießen?
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Reskill, jawoll.
Jetzt bist du in der Queue?
Ernsthaft?
Das Game ist teilweise ziemlich verbackt.
Nur manchmal.
Also so zu 95% der Zeit.
Nein, das ist nicht der Fall.
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Meine Güte, Alter.
Hier ist ja mal...
Ich muss hier runter, Alter.
Meine Güte, Hilfe.
Das ist ja, ist das, ist das SPMM oder was ist hier los?
Komm mal, wie ich so pp gehabt hab, alter.
100 Milliarden, dankeschön, fuck.
Die fetzt sich aber auch hart, man.
Oh, die diffusen, die diffusen, die diffusen, diffusen, Cem.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Boah, das ist da gerade echt anstrengend hier.
Oh, vielleicht krieg ich nen Rätts.
Pass auf, da sind welche.
Nice.
Oder auch nicht.
Die Gegner sind schon ziemlich heftig drauf gerade.
Ich brauch das andere.
Ah, ich hab das Trum-Mack bestimmt unlocked mittlerweile.
Fadel, ich hol dich, Sack.
Alter, von hinten wieder.
Meine Güte.
Okay, wo ist er?
Der winnen muss jetzt.
So, mal kurz den Motion Sensor rüber.
Mal gucken.
Oh, fuck.
Grip.
F.
Oh, oh, oh, das war schlecht.
Ich bin direkt vorm Auto gespawnt.
Bester, bester Spotpunkt, sehr gut gemacht, Max.
Perfekt.
Direkt vorm Auto.
Null.
Heck.
Wie läuft's auch ziemlich gut eigentlich?
Kann man nix sagen.
By the way, das ist die überarbeitete Map.
Nur mal so, wo muss ich denn überhaupt hin?
Scheiße, man.
Die Map ist zwar überarbeitet, aber es ist immer noch nix.
MonkaS.
Alter.
Überarbeitet schön und gut.
Was kostet das Game?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Oh, yes, nice.
Spawn.
Oh, nee.
Jetzt mich rein.
Yeah.
Tja, ich glaube, das Game wird noch zum Neupreis verkauft, oder?
Or, or not.
Früher hat man dazu Commander Krieger-Aim gesagt.
Oh Gott, an jede Ecke, hinter jedem Busch, man.
60 Euro ist immer noch ganz schön heftig, ja.
Wo ist das Aim-Com?
Fahren wir nicht falsch?
What the hell?
Die Fahrzeuge sind schon merkwürdig teilweise.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Ich musste mich mal kurz...
Die sind krass, die Gegner, Alter.
Du kommst hier keine zwei Meter weit.
Was können wir denn machen?
Wir haben ja auch keinen Heli.
Heli wäre jetzt ganz praktisch.
Einmal haben wir gelegt, wir haben noch sieben Tickets, das wird nix, Leute.
Das wird nix.
Noch sieben Tickets.
Also entweder kommen wir jetzt durch, ohne zu sterben und legen, was nicht so aussieht.
Noch fünf Tickets.
Da ist ein Auto, ja, nice.
Oh, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog, Pog.
We are pulling out an our TP, the enemy is one.
Lost.
Spiel lieber Genshin, aber ich war doch noch nie in einer Wüste.
Wie soll das denn funktionieren?
How you lost last plant?
Lass mich raten, er hat geplantet und ist stinkig.
Wir haben das ganz einfach, wie wir last plant gelostet haben.
Der Typ mit dem Auto ist an den Rand der Map gefahren, anstatt das Mcom zu verteidigen.
Warum?
Man weiß es nicht genau.
So, was haben wir wieder gekriegt?
Okay, zeig ich mal her.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, vielleicht sollten wir das mal ausrüsten.
Spiel lieber, übrigens, ich hab noch nie Genshin gespielt, also nicht, dass es jetzt
vielleicht so gewirkt hätte, als wüsste ich auch nur entfernen, wovon ich rede.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, das einzige, woher ich Genshin kenne, ist vom Fabian, als der das
am Anfang gestreamt hat, ein bisschen.
Weapons, warte mal, ne, wo sind wir?
Da sind wir.
Wie, das ist immer noch nicht anlockt.
Monkeys, Alter.
Noch 40 Kills, na gut.
Wollen wir nicht so sein.
Das sucht gerade gar kein Game, oder?
Hat sich so angehört.
Ja, ich gebe zu, ich hab schon sehr überzeugend vorgetragen, das Sponsoring, kann man schon
mal denken, ich bin Genshin Experte.
War ganz, wirklich, no, Kaleidoskop, come on.
Gibt es nix anderes mehr?
Chat, ich zieh noch mal raus, ich hab keinen Bock, noch mal Kaleidoskop.
Ich such noch mal neu, ich mein, das Game hat zwar nicht viele Maps, Leaf Game, das
hat zwar nicht viele Maps, aber mehr als eine hat's und die viermal hintereinander Kaleidoskop
hab ich auch keinen Bock.
Auch wenn's ne überarbeitete Map ist.
Wir könnten Rush Master spielen, oder wie das hieß.
Dann kriegen wir wenigstens zwei neue Maps.
Ja, komm, wisst ihr was?
Kennste?
Master of Arms Rush.
Dann kriegen wir definitiv Renewal oder Stranded.
Haben wir beides heute kaum gespielt, Renewal noch gar nicht und Stranded glaub ich nur
einmal.
Gibt nur einen Server mit genug Spielern, ja.
Klingt jetzt blöd, wird aber wahrscheinlich so sein in dem Spiel.
Wieviel?
Wartet mal, gerade während das lädt.
Äh, wie sieht's denn gerade aus, Spielerzahlen?
Ach, für Battlefield 20 42 Verhältnisse, echt, echt okay.
Kann man nix sagen.
10.000 Spieler, das ist das Doppelte bis Dreifache, was es relativ lange hatte.
Okay, auf geht's.
Gerade Runden anfangen, Defense.
Da könnten wir ein bisschen spät sein, die sind schon mit dem LLV direkt an dem...
Meistens gehen die Gegner zuerst auf A, aber das ist immer so ein bisschen random.
Also Leute, übrigens auch überarbeitete Map.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, ich muss da oben drauf.
Ha, Leute, defused, defused und gekillt dabei, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh shit, das erste, was man sieht, rote Container, pass mal auf, Renewal wird die Containerfans
wird euch begeistern, die haben nicht nur rote Container, die haben grüne Container,
die haben sogar, ihr seht's noch nicht richtig, doch, da ist es ein bisschen, die haben sogar
blaue Container, überlegt euch mal, get, gettet das mal, ja?
Drei farbige Container, massivster Pog, shit, oh, C5, schon geil, ja, schon geil und ich
glaube, die haben sogar, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, es könnte sein, es könnte sogar
sein, dass die sogar noch braune Container haben.
Schrei nicht so rum, Mensch, okay, okay, B, B, äh, was, Moment, lebt doch?
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, das ist er, aah, der hat Armor gehabt, shit, okay, aah, okay,
okay.
Übrigens, keinen Fallschaden, wenn man nach unten, Gravitation ist nicht existent für
Battlefield, braucht man nicht, overrated, Erdanziehung, wer braucht sowas schon?
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist das kleinste Problem, das das Game hat.
Gravitation outdated overrated she baited
Da läuft was, da läuft was, was ist da? Guck mal da
Keine Chance, nice nur noch 34 Tickets easy
Normalerweise wird die erste Base übelst schnell überrannt
Kurz andere seite checken ob da noch was ist
Da ist was ich sehe nix weil
Auf fett fach fach fach ich dachte da ist was ok jetzt habe ich ein problem
Achtung
Nix gemacht die runde außer von a nach b gerannt aber es hat funktioniert easy
Wie das ding nach oben zieht trotz tabs
Darf ich auch mal rein
Ich habe noch nie geschossen mit dem ding ich warte jetzt bis der weg geht und dann dann gehe ich auch mal rein
Und dann dann gehe ich auch mal rein
Ob der geht nicht weg glaube da bleibt bis zum bitteren in seiner komischen gettling an hocken
Lohne Reserves
Rupes okay die haben es aufgegeben kommt nix mehr durch
Leute spiele alle von euch dota 2
Keine sorge ich will weder mit euch spielen noch fange ich hier an dota zu streamen oder so interessiert mich nur
Ich gucke in letzter zeit extrem gerne dota streams
mit das mega
Spannend und entspannend zeitgleich
3500 stunden ok das heißt du bist einsteiger jetzt du hast quasi einsteiger geschafft mit 3000 stunden
Das spiel ist ja übelst kompliziert ich weiß ich spiele gar nicht ich bin reiner zuschauer das heißt ich checke noch weniger
Das spiel ist ja übelst kompliziert alle ich weiß ich spiele gar nicht ich bin reiner zuschauer das heißt ich checke noch weniger
Aber das ist wirklich six hat
Ich gucke ich gucke mega gerne dota und
Ich finde es auch spannend und spannend und entspannend gleichzeitig
Warum nicht loll weiß nicht loll gefällt mir nicht zu gucken also ich spiele weder loll noch dota aber
Also ich habe das das einser dota wurde in den warcraft die wort ist ja kein mod die ist es ein custom map gewesen
Davon gab es ja auch mehrere in dieser richtung
Bisschen gespielt aber das ist nicht der rede wert
Ja
Du guckst voll gerne world of tanks aber zockt das ach world of tanks leute
Fällt mir doch einer muss ich mal kurz in meine email gucken ich habe ein
Sponsoring angebot von world of tanks bekommen
Und wenn ich das so ähnlich machen kann wie genshin dann ist es kein ding
Denn da erzähle ich euch dann world of tanks ist das leading tank blabla blabla game und ihr könnt jetzt den neuen tank ausprobieren
Wenn ihr den qr konnte in meiner beschreibung gehen ha ha ich war noch nie in einem tank und ich freue mich so sehr dass
Ich einen tank fahren darf holladet euch jetzt
Da war ich da wieder den krassen sell out
auf geht's
Ich war noch nie in einer wüste ich muss mich so weg püsten leute man hört es glaube ich im video ja
Genshin jetzt mal ohne mist ich glaube
Und diesen ganzen free to play games ist genshin immer noch das beste wo man zumindest die ersten
Frag mir nicht 50 stunden oder so spielen kann ohne richtig krass rein zu cashen
Und und eins muss man sagen
Genshin ist das voll das frauen spiel
Also wer mit medels was zum reden haben will muss genshin impact spielen
Kannst du sagen und hast du schon auf wie heißt der neu ich habe ich habe es vorgelesen wie heißen die neuen helden
li lu li lu
Ich habe vergessen keine ahnung ich werde es auch nicht spielen
Du kennst nur cringe weeps die da spielen
Es sind nicht es sind nicht nur cringe weeps kann ich dir kann ich dir sagen
Ein kollega auf der arbeit hat seine freunde über genshin kennengelernt siehste siehste also ich weiß dass das komplette female valorant team von einem
Den namen will ich sagen also von von jemanden ich kenne
Der coach das und der meint die spielen alle valorant die spielen alle genshin anstatt valorant aber
Female team
Manchmal manchmal frage ich mich immer so
Also ich bin voll dafür dass es female teams gibt los muss man das disclaimer dazu sagen sonst
beschweren sich damit
Leute
Bei manchen orgas habe ich den eindruck die haben die female teams einzeln allein als werbe
placement und nicht so sehr für tatsächlich
turniere spielen
Okay hier rest mich keiner
Alter die sind schon an a dran da fuck ich habe drei gekillt auf den weg zu a wie können die schon da dran sein die
die weeps wieder hier
Frag mich nicht was das mit weeps zu tun hat
Wahrscheinlich weil genshin
Hat mit weeps überhaupt nichts zu tun wo ist den baro eigentlich wenn man ihn braucht
Da wenigstens einer weiß von bei dem thema bescheid
Da war ppega style Ppega im
Okay, das war Pepega-Style.
Pepega, Pepega aim, richtig krass wieder, alter Max, du musst dich mal länger als zwei
Stunden konzentrieren können aufs Game, das geht mit 38 auch.
Stell dich mal nicht so an, alter, Kacknoob.
Ich merke das, wenn ich länger als zwei Stunden oder eineinhalb Stunden gespielt habe, ich
fange an mega hirnlos zu spielen, ich renne rein ohne zu gucken und gebe mir überhaupt
nicht mehr Mühe, man zielt einfach hoch, wo sind wir denn hier, alter, das ist mitten
im Gegnersporn.
Kann ich nicht resten, sorry, okay, die sterben nicht, nice, GG Eats, oh, oh, oh, der pusht,
C4, den habe ich nicht gesehen, oh, danke, danke, oh, oh, oh, pock, pock, pock, pock,
pock, ripp, aber das ist gut, solange die uns hier am Spawnrape hindern, umso weniger
können sie reinpushen, eigentlich richtig progge, ach shit, das wäre so ein cooler Flank
gewesen.
Okay, Max, wieder konzentrieren, aufhören hirnlos reinzurennen.
Fertig, kann ich da nicht resten, du leckst in der Wand, okay, konzentrieren.
Ha, der Typ im Spawn, keck, wo sind die Subs, der Accusing, ich glaube, wir hatten heute
schon 15 Subs oder so, sieht schon taktischer aus, ja, ja, das ist wirklich so, nach einer
halben Stunde, also ich schalte voll das Gehen ab, früher konnte ich acht Stunden durchspielen,
konzentriert am Stück, das geht nicht mehr, wenn ich eine halbe Stunde gespielt habe und
ich mich nicht selbst zusammenreiße, pepege ich nur noch rum oder treffe nichts, aber gut,
das mache ich auch so nicht, guck schon wieder, normalerweise werde ich da nie raus gerannt,
richtig hängen geblieben, was macht der Typ da oben, der aimt doch hier ab, hat er gerätzt,
ich hoffe nicht, ach Mensch, das Ding ist, guck mal, wenn ich die SMG auf range kille,
das ist echt so, wirklich, Rentner-Extrem, Boomer, richtig, richtig Boomer-Time, schon
spät Leute, schon spät, jetzt kommen sie ganz schön von der Seite herangepusht, guck
mal, fast verreckt, obwohl ich den drei Sekunden vorher gesehen habe, links, links ist wieder
und jetzt sind die schon drinnen oder so am Dach, top, der ist auf dem Dach, ok, zehn
Tickets noch, easy win Leute, easy win, wo ist denn der, wisst ihr wie cool es wäre,
wenn mal Leute spotten könnten in dem Spiel, da würdest du auch was sehen, total dumm darunter
zu laufen, ne Vollpreis würde ich auf gar keinen Fall kaufen, niemals, ganz schön blöde
von mir, nice, win, good, gg, Lowbrow and Boomer-Action, korrekt, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
af 20 gehts Abwärts Leute, wie stehst du eigentlich zu Valorant, ich spiele kein Valorant, ich
Ich gucke kein VALORANT RULE 34
ähm
Ich...
Schaue kein VALORANT eSport
Und ich interessiere mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht groß vor VALORANT
Hat sich das Spiel verbessert? Ja, es gibt jetzt Rush und ein gescheites Hauptmenü
Viele Bugs sind aber immer noch da
Vorhin beispielsweise wieder verbuggte Laubi gehabt, von einem Spiel, was nicht aufhört
zigmal, dass Leute nicht nachjoinen können und sonst was, ist halt
Es ist halt immer noch ziemlich kaputt und das ganze irgendwie neun oder ne elf Monate, glaube ich jetzt, vor Release
Das ist da schon ganz schön lang her
Wann kam das raus? November? Anfang November? Gar nicht, Ende Oktober
Wird geruscht
Komm hier mal
Wenigstens habe ich nach der Runde wahrscheinlich das Magazin anlockt
So, wir können jetzt auf A gehen, aber wir machen hier die Sixhead Action und flanken mal durch auf B
In der Hoffnung, dass uns keiner gesehen hat
Ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht, da hat der doch schon Gegner am Start
Darf ich noch mal was killen heute?
Ganz schön viel los, aber die haben wir ganz schön überrannt jetzt
Die haben wir ganz schön überrannt
Oh, da kommt einiges jetzt hier
Guckt euch mein PP gar eh man, Wahnsinn
Das gehört zu konzentraten, schon direkt am verkacken
Da habe ich aber Glück gehabt, dass die genauso PP gehabt haben wie ich
Lasst mich in Ruhe, weg da, ich muss jetzt nice flank action machen
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein
Lasst mich in Ruhe, kann ich nicht holen, wer auch immer, spawnen lieber bei mir rein
Wenn ich zurückgehe an der Stelle, der aimt immer noch ab, spawn bei mir rein, wenn ich im Schiff bin
Easy, easy
Einmal weggeguckt
Alter, Shotgun, nee, nee, Shotgun, Granat, Granat, Noobtub wieder
Weg Noobtubt
Noobröhrt, Noob mit der Noobröhre
Noobtubt, what the fuck
Was, was geht hier ab
Hallo, ich kann nicht aufstehen
Noobröhrt, Noobröhrt
Krapels out, pass mal auf
Massive, Massive, hier pass mal auf, hier, hier ist beste Pose, beste Pose auf der ganzen Map
Exynoscope
Nee, der ist nicht gestorben
Was denn aktuell, was denn aktuell, noch ein gutes Assault Reife
Der Typ ist immer noch da, oder
Ah, direkt, Scar M4, du meinst die M16, oder? M4 gibt es glaube ich nicht
M16
One man army, ja, hätte ich sofort ausgerüstet, Noobtub am Start
Flank, Flank Action
Komm mal, Leute, hier wieder, ganzen Kubernetes Cluster ausgeleert
Docker Files am Start
Nein, Mensch
Killen ist übrigens verboten gerade, ich darf nichts mehr töten
Ich muss nur gucken, dass da nichts von hinten kommt, ok, vielleicht, komm
Lul
Oh, da ist ein Schneiber, Schneiber, Dude, Schneiber, man
Äh, Granate war doch gar nicht mehr da, da oben ist er
Nee, nee, du rats mich bloß nicht, ich mach Docker Compose Refresh erstmal
Der macht das gleiche wie ich, der gammelt da oben auf dem Schiff
Ok, die erwische ich
Da oben, fuck, ich dachte er umläuft mich
Out, Enterhakt, äh
Alter
Wie viel ist da auf dem Schiff los, man
Aber wir haben schon, easy, guck mal, während wir Schiff Action machen
Während wir Schiff Action machen gewinnen wir einfach die Runde
Easy
Ich mein, so kann man es auch machen, alle auf dem Schiff verrückt machen und unten werden die ganzen
Lege Hände in die Eier legen, easy win, outstanding Performance
Wir könnten mal LMG ausprobieren, ob es gescheite LMG's gibt
Ey, vorher machen wir, äh, Trommelmagazin
Porke
So, wieder Zeugs unlockt, was mich nicht juckt
Wieder Battle Pass Progression unlockt, die mich auch nicht juckt
Wir können schnell den Trailer gucken
Äh, Trailer von
The Finals, ah ne, das Game geht schon los, oder? Ah ne, wie ist das denn, The Finals
So, das ist das Game, ach so, ihr seht gar nichts, gell
Ich hab ja nur, ach Mist, ich hab ja Ingame Capture an
Richtig, richtig blöder
Ich hab immer noch kein Trommelmagazin freigeschaltet, na toll
Das einzig gute MLG ist die Avant, was Avant, Avantie
Also sprich, packen wir das doch mal
Äh, das da, was muss man da für machen zum unlocken
34, 34 was, ach Battle Pass tier 34
Ah, äh, und wo sind wir? Zwei und, oh
Will ich das wirklich, was kostet das?
Kekel, ich geb dafür doch kein Geld aus
Wie viel Battle, wie viel Battle Feed Points hab ich eigentlich?
Hab das, hat das irgendjemand gesehen gerade? Oh, neue Map, da war das neue Map
Überarbeitete Map
Vielleicht mal als Attacker, wäre auf jeden Fall nice
Mach die Weekly Challenge, ja, aber da muss ich Sachen machen, die ich nicht machen will
Zum Beispiel Looptube Kills und Melee Kills und so komisches Zeug
No Pass
Spiel ich lieber so, wie ich Bock hab
Oh, wir sind mal tatsächlich Attacker, komm, gib ihm
Attack Sword, will ich mitfahren? Ja, nehm ich mit
Was sind das, Bots? Ah, sind, sind zwei Bots drinne
Die müssten aber gleich viel Place, achso ich bin Fahrer
Guck mal, die haben Tablet mit dem Auto drauf, was sich nicht bewegt
Oh, oh, oh
Versuch das mal zu schaffen, das wird nix
Outplayed by Bots
Oh, mega Lul
Ok, na, ist schön wieder reinsporn
Alter, jetzt Mensch, oh, da ist noch ein Gegner
Ok, also, die haben mich gesehen, aber wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen jetzt da durch, pass mal auf
Ok, Alter, das kannst du wirklich nicht Dauerfeuer machen, das ist
Bigger
Ok, die Gegner sind einfach nur total, total hirnlos, Alter
Lol, sind die blöde
Ich hab, Leute, ich schwöre, ich hab gedrückt
Das war nämlich Sixheadplay, ich wollte von hinten einfach reinflanken
Nice, danke für das Movement Game
Er war zu langsam von mir
Ja, ich hätte das, glaube ich, halt einfach in andere Prosi machen müssen
Kollege, so einfach mache ich es dir nicht
Die Rätsel
So, jetzt können wir langsam durchpushen, denke ich mal
Von hinten reinflanken, ja, so muss es sein
Sich reinschieben
Was, das war nicht in Range
Habt ihr gesehen, ich hab den, ich hab den gesperrt mit meiner
Grappling Gun
Ok, jetzt ist es natürlich schwierig hier rüber zu kommen
Ok, jetzt haben sie gute Posis, jetzt haben sie gute Posis
Smoke, wir brauchen Smoke
Wir brauchen Smoke, ganz wichtig
Wir brauchen keine komische Dingsmine, wir brauchen keine EMP
Keine EMP, was ist denn hier von Smoke, das da
Auch von hinten, ihr werdet Gatchibust, Leute
Was denn das, ok
Eingesmoked
Ok, ich hab keine Muni mehr
Mit dem PC aktuell, ne, ich hab eine 1080 Ti, das ist nicht aktuell
Leute, das wird knapp
Ok, mit der Muni über die Range wird das nichts
Aber danach Trommelmagazin
3 Stunden ohne Rangequit, es ist erstaunlich, gell
Der PC ist noch aktuell, also wenn es der PC mit der 1080 Ti ist, ja, dann ist es noch aktuell
Und man mag es
Hallo
Hallo, game
Und man mag es kaum glauben, der ist noch aktuell
Es ist aber alles, alles auf Low
Achtung, Achtung, den outplayen wir jetzt, der kommt hier runter
Ich wusste es, die Weebs
Wisst bitte nicht, was es mit Weebs zu tun ist
Nix, die Weber
Leute, ich hör hier 50 Gegner laufen, aber es ist gar nichts
Ok, PP-Gard
Wann wird der erneuert?
Na ja, planmäßig Ende des Jahres eigentlich, das Ding ist jetzt 5 Jahre alt
Aber das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie das mit den Nvidia-Grafikkarten wird
Also, ich hab ausgerechnet, ich brauch ungefähr 4500 Euro für einen neuen Rechner in der Kombi, die ich haben will
Das ist im Ernst, wenn der mal 1000 Euro billiger wäre, hätte ich auch kein Problem mit
Die Grafikkarte ist halt einfach nur sau und teuer, jeder will nicht sterben
What? Dankeschön
Jetzt, pass mal auf, das hier muss alles weg
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein
Pass mal auf, Massive, Massive Sixer
Shit, ich will aufs Dach
AMD kommt nicht in Frage
Ja, für die CPU
CPU-technisch wird das wahrscheinlich in AMD
Ah, what? Alter, das ist schnell gewesen
CPU-technisch wird's wahrscheinlich AMD
GPU-technisch eigentlich Nvidia geplant
Fuck, die wollten mich alle razen, ich bin einfach nur in Tod gebaitet
You got jebaited
AMD ist die Frage, doch AMD kommt auch in Frage, je nachdem, was die vorstellen
Mal schauen, was AMD für Grafikkarten vorstellt
Mal schauen
Mensch, wir kommen jetzt nicht raus
Ich will bloß nicht geflankt werden
Oh, das ist eine Smog, ich hab grad keine
Ich dachte, ich hab noch den Bewegungssensor dabei
Nice, easy
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Ja, Smog ist gute Deckung, wenn man sie ordentlich wirft und nicht vor sich
Hallo, danke
Aufs Dach
Ja, so, unter mir
Ah, shit, das hat er gut gemacht, er wusste genau, wo ich stehe
Er hat sich bewegt und ich bin nicht stehen geblieben
Er ist nicht stehen geblieben, er hat sich bewegt und ich bin stehen geblieben
Er wusste, wo ich war und ich Shooter Basics nicht befolgt
Also, Faker, ich würd dich ressen, wenn ich wüsste, von wo es hier grade schießt
Das ist ein bisschen planlos
Ok, B noch, dann haben wir's
Au, Monkeys, Alter
Können wir aufhören, mich die ganze Zeit von hinten zu killen
Alter, 26, 10, der nächste hat 7, wir haben richtig gehaunt
Was ist da los?
Hier wäre es wieder nicht möglich gewesen
Massive Team-Erfolg hier
Auf, komm, springt mir doch mal einer
Ich wollte gerade sagen, springt mir doch mal einer, jetzt Fadenkreuz
Also, wenn wir nicht Erster sind, Squad, weiß ich auch nicht
Massive Squad-Erfurt
Outstanding Performance
More Skills, Leute, wir haben alle drei Karten am Ende
Und Squad 1, ja, so ist gut, muss sein
So mag ich das
Das verstehe ich nicht, die hätten theoretisch einfach nur den MKOM Sound kopieren müssen
Den neuen MKOM Sound mag ich auch nicht
Giga-Chat-Medic, ja
Ich bin mal gespannt, was AMD zeigt an Grafikkarten
Wann ist denn das, wann wird denn das vorgestellt oder wurde das schon vorgestellt?
Also, die neuen Ryzen-CPUs sind schon da?
Also, vorgestellt und nicht erschienen
Wobei, 4. Oktober, 1. Oktober, die kommen doch jetzt irgendwie raus, oder?
Die Ryzen-Dinger
So Leute, wir müssen mal ein bisschen was anderes spielen, spielen wir so eine Runde SMG
Kein Bock, immer
Wobei, habe ich jetzt eigentlich das Magazin frei gespielt?
Habe ich jetzt gar nicht gecheckt?
Wie viele hatte ich 26 Kills?
Da müsste ich jetzt eigentlich das Trommelmagazin haben
Weapons
Yo
Nice
Ja
Ja, sehr schön
Sehr schön, da können wir jetzt ein bisschen länger ppega aimen, bis uns die Puste ausgeht
Wisst ihr, ich bin immer noch begeistert
5 Jahre alt ist der Rechner, den ich da bestellt habe
Und ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, das ist für mich, als Generation der Leute, die sich alle eineinhalb Jahre früher neue Rechner kaufen müssen
Komplett unverständlich, dass das überhaupt möglich ist
Das ist ein Bot
Keck, wait, das ist ein Bot
Oh Mann, die Hälfte besteht wieder aus Bots, Alter
Es dauert jetzt wieder 3 Minuten, bis er aufgefüllt ist
Was hat sich DICE nur mit dieser Bot-Kacke gedacht?
Ernster, was ist das für ein Crab, Mann?
Guckt euch das an
Als wäre das wirklich eine gute Idee gewesen, da Bots einzufügen
Besser als Solo in der Lobby?
Nö, das Spiel sollte einfach nicht starten
Das Spiel sollte bei 80% Spieler starten
Und nicht starten, nur weil es mit Bots aufgefüllt ist
Ja, das ist halt dumm, dass überhaupt Bots drin sind
Guckt euch das an
Keck, da wird es los
L. Potter spielt bei den Gegnern mit
Casuals müssen auch was treffen, das Game ist so easy, Leute
Ich bin der größte Boomer und bashe eigentlich größtenteils der Runden
Das sollte alles sagen
Ich meine, ich bin Boomer mit ziemlich viel Battlefield
Stunden insgesamt
Aber trotzdem, das Game ist easy
Also wenn sich da einer beschwert, dass er nichts auf die Reihe kriegt, dann weiß ich auch nicht
Das ist eigentlich kein Ding
Guck mal, jetzt ist das Game voll
Jetzt können wir uns wieder anstrengen
Gravitation, overrated, outdated
Chebated
Direkt
Gucken, ob die über die andere Seite flanken
Ich meine, die wären clever, wenn sie noch über die andere Seite gehen würden, obwohl das M-Com schon weg ist
Aber so clever sind sie anscheinend nicht
Die gehen straight auf A
Wachs vielleicht
Rock
So, mal wieder in meine Lieblingsecke auf der Map
In der Hoffnung, mich trifft das Auto nicht
Beste Ecke
Dich kann nichts, dich kann kaum was killen
Und du kannst alles sehen
Ok, Gegner sind alle aufgefüllt
Das ist jetzt schwierig, wenn der Typ da oben steht
Das Ding ist auf range, so rotzig
Hier drüben ist nichts mehr
Ich dachte eigentlich, da sind ein paar rüber gegangen, aber anscheinend nicht
Mein Team hat es easy im Griff, guckt euch das mal an, die kommen überhaupt nicht ran
Doch, da ist doch einer, sag ich doch
Nein
Mit dem letzten Leben
Aber das ist ein Medic neben mir, vielleicht rettet er mich
High IQ Spieler
Guck mal, wie manchmal der Medic panisch geht
Bombi
Alter, das fliegt durch den Kopf durch, oder?
Nice
Nein, die lege Henne ist da, die haben nur noch 30 Tickets
Jetzt haben wir wieder nicht aufgepasst
Richtig, richtig, Ausrufezeichen PP geeint
Richtig dumm
Ich dachte, easy win, easy win, es ist wieder rumgehampelt und dann zack nichts
Da müssen wir uns jetzt nächste Base anstrengen, richtig verkackt wieder
Das kriegen wir nicht mehr, ich glaube das ist dead
Ja, boom
Big shock
Ja, Chet, ihr habt recht, ihr habt recht
Oh, Tazer, Pog, Dankeschön, 10 Abos
Massive Subscriptions hier, Dankeschön, Dankeschön, wir hatten was gekriegt hier, das Plexer Overlord
Opmus aus Leku, ja, der ist oft da, der hat es verdient
Captain Schufi, Semmel, Rageman, Zoronata, Katsor, Kathos und Filou
Aja, ja
Alter, Schneiberdutz, ach das war gar nicht der oder was
Ok, schnell wieder rein, als Defender ist Sterben nicht schlimm
Ok
Ok, ich hätte eigentlich wecken können, da ist was
Ja, so nicht, oh die haben geplantet
Hätte ich mich angestrengt und eben auf Kopf gezielt, wäre er weg gewesen
Also bei mehr als 100 FPS kann man noch die Grafik hörstellen
Ja, ja, ne, ne kann man nicht, erstens willst du ja das möglichst, also du willst ja auch keine Drops drinne haben
Und das Game fühlt sich mit 100 FPS beweite mich so flüssig an wie die anderen Games mit 100 FPS anfühlen
Shit, dazu kommt mehr FPS immer gut, selbst 150, 200 immer mehr FPS besser
Und du hast noch das weitere Problem, das Spiel sieht nicht sonderlich bedeutend viel besser aus
Kommt ja noch dabei, äh, ja, es lohnt sich, Alter, es lohnt sich nicht
Mauslag, ja ich glaube es ist ganz gut
Ich müsste mich erstmal wieder konzentrieren und ordentlich spielen
Leute nach drei Stunden, Boomer war schon nach eineinhalb Stunden müde, aber jetzt ist vorbei
Man is not hot
What
Ich glaube ich habe gegen das stationäre Ding geballert
Die letzte, okay, das vorletzte Base, das ist doch nicht letzte Base, vorletzte Base
Okay, jetzt high IQ Plays rausholen, Leute
High IQ Plays rausholen
Jetzt wird Zeit, ist jetzt notwendig
So, Location Revealed ist glaube ich schlecht
Okay, Leute, könnt ihr vergessen
Aber immerhin noch ein bisschen was gekillt, immerhin noch, 1080p
Battlefield 2042 E-Sport Szene, oh ja, Battlefield E-Sport, gab es das jemals?
Gab es jemals wirklich Battlefield E-Sport?
Ich weiß, mein ehemaliger Overwatch Teamkollege hat BRBF4 Competitive gespielt, aber das hatte ja keine wirkliche
Jetzt irgendwie große E-Sport Szene
Leute, hier gibt es tatsächlich mal einen Trick auf der Map, den ich ganz gut finde
Man kann den Container aufmachen, sich da drin verstecken
Ey, ernsthaft wirklich nicht schlecht, weil sonst hast du hier wenig Deckung und wird alles weggesprengt
Sag mal
Haben die schon lege Hände gemacht?
Passt es nicht
Disarmed Champ
Okay, A ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger einzunehmen
In the Cop
Prager, Prager, fuck
War knapp
Chat, ihr habt nicht genug geprayt, ich hab nicht einen Prager Emote gesehen, Chat ist schuld
Easy
Okay
Jetzt ist Prager auch zu spät
Pass auf, der fährt mich gleich um
Da ist er doch, hab doch hier einen gesehen gerade
Also das hier kann man ganz gut Defenden
Irgendwie hat mein Hirn nicht reagiert, dass das ein Gegner ist am Anfang
Ich dachte, das ist ein komisches Gadget an der Wand
Und dann war es ein Gegner
Und fähig
Jetzt
Also Granatenradius abschätzen ist echt nicht so ohne
Ich dachte, das was weit an mir vorbeigeflogen das Ding
Lull
Das können wir halten
Das ist durchaus möglich
Max, ich hole dich
Gibt das immer 50% Damage Assist, 50 XP Damage Assist
Unabhängig davon, ob man überhaupt, wie viel Damage man überhaupt gemacht hat
Scheint so
Oh nice, nice Leute hier
Und jetzt wird gepusht
Immer im falschen Moment
Die Runde geht gar nichts, aber ich merke, mein Boomer hier macht es nicht mal lange mit Leute
Ich glaube, ich brauche ein bisschen irgendwas anderes
Close, close, close
Schau ich mal an, ich treffe nichts mehr
Die Map sieht weiter aus besser aus
Ja
Vor allem mehr Container
Fuck, alle tot
Shit
Deutlich mehr Container
Und Kisten und Absperrungshütchen
Was du heute Abend essen sollst Spaghetti
Max, ich hätte dich geholt
Oder leg, lege Hände, lege Hände
Loll
Eine Runde spielen wir noch
Obwohl
Abhängig von der Map
Abhängig von der Map, also wenn jetzt Discarded oder irgend so ein Müll kommt
Dann
Nicht
In der Zwischenzeit gucken wir uns mal kurz an
Der neue Trailer von dem Spiel der Battlefield, Battlefield, der Ex Battlefield Macher
Embark Studios heißen die jetzt
Alter, das sieht so Hipster mäßig aus wie Apex, ich weiß net
Es hat wenig mit Battlefield zu tun auf jeden Fall
Na wobei, wobei, ganz ehrlich
Sieht aus wie Battlefield mit Superkräften
Ja mehr, mehr Effekt, Overload bitte
Das ist quasi so Battlefield mit
Overwatch
Aber es ist jetzt nicht Frostbite, das ist glaube ich Unreal Engine
Aber und das muss man schon mal dem Game zugute halten
Bevor wir es gespielt haben
Es hat irgendwie so einen gewissen eigenen Charakter und Style, auch wenn es ein bisschen Apex Hipster aussieht
Es ist aber von der Grafik her schon wieder gar nicht mehr
Das hier könnte jetzt 1 zu 1 ein Apex Held sein, aber ansonsten
Ja
Und man sieht Gameplay
Es ist nicht irgendein komisches Cinematic Ding, ja
Also Cinematic ist trotzdem, aber wir sind in keinem, so stellen wir es uns mal theoretisch vor, also nicht wie Battlefield Trailer da am Anfang
Ok, einmal noch Stranded, neue Map zum Abschluss ist gut
Weiß man ob das auch für PS5 kommt?
Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass die meisten Games heutzutage für PS5, PC und Xbox kommen
Oder Console Exklusiv
PC Exklusiv gibt es doch?
Fällt euch irgendwas?
PC Exklusiv ist ein der letzten Jahre so in Mainstream mäßig
Also ich meine damit ist nicht Rust oder sowas, wobei selbst Rust ist glaube ich nicht PC Exklusiv oder?
Kann da mal einer sterben?
Sterben please?
Stadia Only ja Stadia Only zählt nicht, Stadia Only ist
Dead
Killed by Google
Valorant, ist Valorant PC Exklusiv?
Oh Leute ich kann nicht mehr spielen
Monka
Ich kann nicht mehr zielen wirklich es ist vorbei, es ist vorbei
Boomer Hirn ist überfordert
Guckt euch an einfach raus gerannt
Was Valorant soll für Mobile kommen?
Wirklich?
Mobile?
Ernsthaft?
Also das letzte worauf ich mir ein aimlastiges Spiel wie Valorant vorstellen kann ist ja
mal tatsächlich mobile
Oh shit zu spät
Also wenn du das, wenn du Valorant auf mobile spielen willst, das brauch ja einen integrierten
Aimbot, dass es überhaupt funktioniert
Das ist, das ist, ich mein es ist kein CS, aber es ist schon ein äußerst aim und point
und click so click head dead game
Ganz schön viel los da drin
Einfach Yolo reingesprungen
Ok mal gucken ob der alte Mann es schafft sich nochmal zu konzentrieren für eine Viertelstunde
Nope
Oh Reds?
Reds, Reds, Reds, Reds, Reds, Reds
Gibt's nicht
Viertelstunde ja
Oh ein nicer Spawn wenn's geht
Der da?
Leute mag's nochmal 10 Minuten konzentrieren alter, können das easy gewinnen wenn ich ordentlich
bin
8 Stunden am Stück ist vorbei Leute kann ich da mal machen
Alter der stirbt nicht
Ok wenigstens wenigstens ein bisschen was gemacht, wenigstens ein bisschen was gemacht, 3 gekillt
Nice, ok wir haben A, weiter geht's, außen rum, außen rum, shit
Ok Max ich hol dich, nein mach ich nicht
Sag mal, können die oben kippen?
Der wird einfach abgesmokt jetzt, abgesmokt und pushen
Fuck, Munition ja
Für welchen Preis meinst du denn würd man sich das Game antun? 15 Euro
15 Euro und dann durchgehend Rush spielen und gut ist
Oh nee, Mann wieviel Tickets haben wir noch?
19 ok letzte, letzte Attack
Pass auf wir faken jetzt, Sixhead
Die denken jetzt wir kommen hinten lang, machen wir aber gar nicht
Ausgerechnet da ist einer
Ok wenn wir jetzt nicht durchkommen wird das nix
Ok ein paar Sachen gekillt
Die aim nicht in den Rauch, die schauen nur wo sich was bewegt, ja das stimmt
Fuck, na gut, boah das reicht mir aber ey, Alter
Dreieinhalb Stunden ist für mich echt genug, dass das Maximum erreicht
Es gibt ja Leute, es gibt ja Leute, konnte ich früher auch
Die haben acht Stunden am Stück durchgespielt und dann so wie die erste Stunde quasi
Und die sind erst aufgewärmt nach drei Stunden
So haben wir noch irgendwas sinniges unlocked
Was denn das da?
Shotgun?
Egal
Wie turnen wir mal zum Menü
Es gibt auch Leute die machen das zwanzig und ja es gibt auch Leute die machen
Irgendwelche Sub, Sub, Sabaton wie auch immer
Streams für achtundvierzig Stunden
MonkaS, Alter jetzt reicht's
Dudel anmachen
Das will ich mir nicht angucken
Ja
Chat, gibt's noch irgendwelche spannenden Sachen
Was ist denn so passiert die letzten paar Tage
Google hat Stadia dicht gemacht
Chrome wirft Adblocker raus
Wobei das sich ja wahrscheinlich schon wieder erstmal gelegt hat für ein weiteres Jahr
Was hältst du von den Twitch Veränderungen, was gab's denn da die letzte Woche
Oder meinst du allgemein so die letzten paar Jahre über
Gab es die letzte Woche irgendwelche großen Twitch Veränderungen
Ach so 50 50 für alles mir egal
Ah ja Glücksspielverbot
Bezos kann sich nicht leisten
Ja das haben wir zusammen gesehen und ich bin immer noch der Meinung ich kaufe mir wahrscheinlich eine 40,90
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich bin der Preis ist krass das ist es
Es doppelte von der 1080 Ti damals
Wobei die haben ja nicht mal bezahlt aber trotzdem
Twitch Werbung ist richtig tatsächlich das ist was was mich wirklich nervt
Twitch Werbung ist total übertrieben seit ein paar Wochen
Laufen ist irgendwo Werbung
Die Gambling Streamer sind süchtig bestimmt ein Großteil ja
Ja wahrscheinlich ein Großteil aber auf der anderen Seite
Für die ist es halt insofern geil
Die können quasi gesponsort süchtig sein
Das würden viele am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof auch gerne sein
Da kann ja Free TV ganz ehrlich ich gucke so gut wie kein Fernseher
So gut wie kein Fernseher mehr
Das einzige was ich öffentlich rechtlich konsumiere ab und zu
Ist auf YouTube so Handwerksvideos oder so
Wo irgendwie einer heute bauen wir einen Swimming Pool oder so
Oder heute bauen wir eine Bank oder Tisch oder sowas
Das gucke ich mir manchmal an das ist immer äußerst beruhigend
Das kann ich mir angucken zum einschlafen
Nein ne ne ne 70 30 70 30 ist
Das was früher die ganzen großen also viele große Streamer gekriegt haben
70 für den Streamer
Und 30 für Twitch und bei allen anderen ist es 50 50
Als Traumschiff ne das gucke ich nicht weiß nur dass das mit Florian Silbereisen ist
Falls es das noch ist
Ich baue meine PCs immer zusammen
Serious Max Dankeschön 26 Monate
Massive Subscription
Pog
Lohnt sich das
Was
Bisher hatten immer 50 50
Ne der hat ein neues
Ne das gucken wir uns aber morgen früh an nicht jetzt
40 80 mit 12 mit 16 weil die 40 80 mit 12 gigabyte quasi eine ganz andere
Grafikkarte ist
Das ist nicht nur der Ram der Unterschied ist
Also auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall die mit 16 g
Oder Casino Streams kein zum beiden
Auch wenn ich nicht selbst spiele
Die neuen Nvidia Grafikkarten gibt es wahrscheinlich für UVP nur dass der UVP total Abfahrt hoch ist
Aber ich bin da jetzt mit dem Kram abgestellt habe
Ich bin froh dass ich den Kram abbestellt habe
Ich hatte das damals bestellt weil ich mir gedacht habe einfach mal gucken ich wie gesagt ich habe nie wirklich an Stadia geklaut
Aber ich habe bei einem mal gucken und dann haben sie es irgendwie trotz Vorbestellung verschoben
Da habe ich mir gedacht wisst ihr was ihr könnt mich mal weg
Wenn komplett refundet wahrscheinlich kriegt man für einen Stadia Controller in 20 Jahren 3000 Euro bei einer ebay Aktion für irgendwelche Sammler
Wobei ganz ehrlich wer will so ein Feld wie Stadia haben bei einem Super Nintendo vielleicht aber nicht
Nicht bei einem Stadia Controller
Aber es ist ein neues Video
Das habe ich mir erst gar nicht gegeben
Ich habe eine Weile recht viel Halo Infinite gespielt aber was mich bei Halo Infinite abgefuckt hat war die Geschichte mit
Dass der Controller Support so übertrieben war versus PC
Das ist nicht so dieses das ist nicht in Rahmen von einem Call of Duty Aim Assist wo das auch schon teilweise fragwürdig ist
Gerade wenn es am Model kleben bleibt aber in Halo ist ja wirklich so das stickt richtig dran
Und du siehst das also also es ist so eines der Standard Duelle ja in Halo mit mit
Pass mal auf mess ich mal jetzt mal meinen Master Chief hier
Das ist der Master Chief so und wenn man auf den Master Chief schießt in Halo
Dann läuft der läuft hin und her also die Standard DMR Dinge
One-on-one ist man läuft voreinander links und rechts hin und her und versucht sich auf den Kopf zu schießen
Und mit dem Controller musst du einmal hier irgendwie ungefähr auf diese Region gehen
Und kannst hin und her laufen und es bleibt mehr oder weniger konstant auf dem Kopf
Mit dem PC mit der Maus musst du wirklich den Kopf die Bewegung tracken und auch alles ausgleichen
Weil vielleicht macht er nicht so sondern macht mal so oder oder oder so oder so
Jetzt musst du alles ausgleichen mit dem Controller ist es einfach nur sticky
Also das war riesen also man muss sich mal überlegen
Wenn die Top Letter Spieler fast alle Controller spielen dann stimmt irgendwas nicht
Ja wirklich gut waren die danach ja auch nicht mehr also ich finde
Oder St für die Single Player Kampagne war okay auch wenn der Soundtrack irgendwie weiß nicht warum der Preis gekrönt war
Ich fand nicht so gut
Reach war auch schon so
Ah ja und alles danach kannst du klicken
Bezieht sich jetzt auch was
PC also wie gesagt ich will meinen ich ich wollte mir neuen PC kaufen
Und ich habe hier guck mal kann auch kommen hier ich habe ausgerechnet im Stream letztens ich brauche ungefähr
Skript Internet TXT
Nein das ist was anderes
Das ist in den Video Skript für was war denn das
Die meisten Leuten verzichten aufs Denken
Ja das ist korrekt die meisten Leute verzichten aufs Denken
Da hatte ich wohl recht was ich geschrieben habe aber
Ich suche jetzt eigentlich das
PC
Meine PC Zusammenstellung aber finde ich nicht mehr also die würde 4500 Euro umgekehrt kosten was halt wirklich
Ziemlich hart ist
Skript Internet ich wusste gar nicht
Dass ich hier irgendwelche Video Skript
Das war auch eher so ein so ein ich habe mal irgendwie was aufgeschrieben und weiß nicht ob ich da draußen Video mache
Es war nichts was ich mal aufgenommen habe glaube ich
Oder
Vielleicht war es das letzte Internet Ausbau Video
Ja ich habe auch in 8000 ich habe 8700 keine 1080 Ti
Nö noch nichts das liegt auf dem Sofa
Es ist schon teuer
Ich brauche eigentlich noch gar keinen neuen Rechner ist halt das Ding
Ich würde den neuen Rechner quasi nur kaufen
Weil ich endlich mal wieder neuen Rechner haben will was eigentlich total hängen geblieben ist
Zumal ich eh nur 1080p spiele
Also kein Ding
Na gut wen immer auch sei chat
Ich gehe jetzt auf
Reicht
Reit wen könnte man rein ich weiß nicht keine Ahnung
Ich bin jetzt zu Boomer für überlegen
Der Friseur den würde ich sofort rein
Alphrisi
Wenn er online wäre
Das wäre cool wenn der mal wieder online gehen würde aber kann es ja knicken
Welche Web Games
Alles klar Leute wir sehen uns bis der NCU